Welcome to our second drink of Casual Friday. So you guys, we thought we had covered this episode really well. But then as we dug around into, you know, looking at Casual Friday for these second drinks, we found so much more. Yes, so much more that we actually decided to do a whole episode. It aired in early August called More Casual Friday. It's episode 304 on Office Lady 6.0. And I mean, that's about it.
欢迎来到我们“休闲星期五”的第二杯特饮。伙计们，我们原以为这集已经讲得很透彻了。但当我们深入挖掘，你知道的，在为这些“第二杯特饮”寻找“休闲星期五”的内容时，我们发现了更多。是的，多到我们决定专门做一整集。它在八月初播出，叫作《更多休闲星期五》。这是《办公室女士 6.0》的第 304 集。我想，大概就是这样。
guys, between this and more casual Friday, there you go. That's your second drink. We're just letting you know. There's a whole extra episode. So listen to this original breakdown and then you can go check out more on more casual Friday. Enjoy. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hey, hello, are you in your comfy pants?
伙计们，除了这一集和《更多休闲星期五》，这就是你们的第二杯特饮了。我们只是想让你们知道，还有一整集额外的内容。所以，先听听这次最初的解析，然后你们可以去看看《更多休闲星期五》里的更多内容。尽情享受吧。我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正专门为你们制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周，我们都会解析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你们的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿，你好，你穿上舒适的裤子了吗？
Do you have on a t-shirt and maybe some flip-flops? Why are you saying these things? You can see me. I'm talking to you guys out there. Oh, because it's casual Friday. Because it's casual Friday. Oh, yeah. Why didn't I dress more casually today?
你穿了 T 恤，可能还穿了人字拖吗？你为什么要说这些？你能看见我。我在跟你们这些听众说话。哦，因为今天是休闲星期五。因为今天是休闲星期五。哦，对。我今天为什么没穿得更休闲一点？
I don't know. You look real spiffy. Well, I know why, because we have a special guest. We do. Let's start by saying that Casual Friday is Season 5, Episode 26. Dang. It was written by Anthony Farrell and directed by Brent Forrester. Little tidbit. What is it?
我不知道。你看上去真的很精神。嗯，我知道为什么，因为我们有一位特别嘉宾。确实。我们先从《休闲星期五》是第五季第 26 集开始说起。天哪。它由安东尼·法瑞尔编剧，布伦特·福雷斯特执导。一个小花絮。是什么？
Editor was Claire Scanlan. And our DP was Matt Sown. Hey, I like this team. I do too, and it was the first time this team had worked together on an episode. Wow. Yeah. They did a good job. They did.
剪辑师是克莱尔·斯坎伦。我们的摄影指导是马特·索恩。嘿，我喜欢这个团队。我也喜欢，而且这是这个团队第一次合作拍摄一集。哇。是的。他们做得很好。确实。
Here's your summary. It is Casual Friday. at Dunderbifflin. Finally. It has been reinstated. Michael is back. He's the manager. It's casual Friday again.
这是你的剧情摘要。在邓德·米夫林，今天是休闲星期五。终于。它恢复了。迈克尔回来了。他是经理。又是休闲星期五了。
But some of the employees are taking a few too many liberties with their outfit choices. Like, Angela's not happy. Angel doesn't need to see a grown man's feet. Probably ever. I'm surprised that we didn't see bare feet on Kevin as well. Well, yeah. But here's the thing. The sales team is resentful that Pam and Ryan came.
但有些员工在服装选择上有点太放肆了。比如，安吉拉很不高兴。安吉拉不需要看到一个成年男人的脚。可能永远都不需要。我很惊讶我们没有在凯文身上也看到赤脚。嗯，是的。但问题是，销售团队对帕姆和瑞安加入感到不满。
came on as new salespeople and that they get to keep the clients that they stole from everybody else while they were working at Michael Scott Paper Company. I mean, that's just awkward. Yeah, so there's a bit of a rivalry that's going to happen on this episode today. Mm-hmm. But first, there's a pretty big thing that kicks off this episode. This is an epic cold open. It's the chili spill cold open.
他们作为新销售人员加入，而且在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司工作期间，他们还能保留从其他人那里抢来的客户。我的意思是，这太尴尬了。是的，所以今天这一集里会发生一点竞争。嗯。但首先，这一集开头有一件相当大的事情。这是一个史诗般的冷开场。这就是辣椒泼洒的冷开场。
Oh, my gosh. Kevin's recipe. the pride he takes in it. He tries to make it up the stairs he does and what happens. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Well, we felt like this was the perfect opportunity to speak to the man behind the chili. Brian Baumgartner.
天哪。凯文的食谱。他引以为傲的食谱。他试图把它端上楼梯，他做到了，然后发生了什么。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。嗯，我们觉得这是采访辣椒背后的男人——布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳的绝佳机会。
That's right. Brian is our fast fact one, two, and three today. We can't wait to talk to him. All right. Here he is. Brian. Brian Baumgartner. Hello.
没错。布莱恩是我们今天的第一、第二和第三个快速事实。我们迫不及待想和他谈谈。好了。他来了。布莱恩。布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。你好。
What is happening? I'm so happy to be with you guys. Look at you, buddy. You have a plant. I love that you have a plant. I was told that brings humanity and warm. Oh. What is the award that's over your shoulder?
发生什么事了？我很高兴能和你们在一起。看看你，伙计。你有一株植物。我喜欢你有一株植物。有人告诉我这能带来人性和温暖。哦。你肩膀上面的那个奖是什么？
You know what? No one has ever asked that in all of the Zooms I've been doing for a year and a half. Truly, it always made me laugh. I don't have my college diploma, but I'll read. I have a Penn Foster College, a certificate of completion, which I always thought was a good joke for Kevin Malone in accounting. That is awesome. A certificate of completion, maybe all diplomas say that, but I thought, oh, they're doing a little funny joke. Like, it's not really a degree in accounting.
你知道吗？在我一年半以来参加的所有 Zoom 会议中，从来没有人问过这个问题。真的，它总是让我发笑。我没有大学文凭，但我会读。我有一个宾福斯特学院的结业证书，我一直认为这对会计部的凯文·马龙来说是个不错的笑话。那太棒了。结业证书，也许所有的文凭都这么写，但我当时想，哦，他们是在开个小玩笑。就像，那并不是真正的会计学位。
He took a weekend course. He has a piece of paper for participating. Well, listen, we are here to talk about these. office with you and obviously about this amazing cold open. But Brian, we always ask our guests, how did you get your job on the office? I was walking down Hollywood Boulevard. No. Oh, I like the start of that. No, I feel like my story always seems like a humble brag or something. But my truth is, I moved to Los Angeles and I considered it my job to just watch television. And so I started watching television shows because I was like, well, if I get an audition on this show, don't I need to know what's the style? What's the form? How do the characters generally behave? So I started watching television and I watched this show called the Office, the British version of the office. And I started working with a manager and I called him and I said, if there is a show that is going to be on television, because they announced they were doing a pilot, I was like, this is the show for me.
他参加了一个周末课程。他有一张参与证明。好吧，听着，我们在这里和你谈谈《办公室》，显然还有这个精彩的冷开场。但是布莱恩，我们总是问嘉宾，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我当时正走在好莱坞大道上。不。哦，我喜欢这个开头。不，我觉得我的故事听起来总像是在谦虚地炫耀什么的。但事实是，我搬到了洛杉矶，我把看电视当作我的工作。所以我开始看电视节目，因为我想，如果我能在这个节目里试镜，难道我不应该知道它的风格是什么吗？形式是什么？角色通常是怎么表现的？所以我开始看电视，我看了这个叫《办公室》的节目，英国版的《办公室》。我开始和一位经纪人合作，我打电话给他，我说，如果有一部电视剧要上电视，因为他们宣布他们正在拍试播集，我说，这就是适合我的节目。
And I had an agent at the time. And the agent who I called and said the same thing to said, well, they're looking for unknown people, but not like you unknown. Not like totally unknown. I was like, all right. Thanks a lot. But my manager called and called and called Allison Jones. And I went in and I met with Phyllis and I read.
当时我有一位代理人。我打电话给那位代理人，说了同样的话，他说，嗯，他们在找不知名的人，但不是像你这种不知名。不是那种完全不知名。我说，好吧。多谢了。但我的经理不停地给艾莉森·琼斯打电话。我进去了，见了菲利斯，我读了剧本。
And then she passed me on to Allison Jones. and I read with her, and I got an appointment for the role of Stanley. And I knew that was not the part for me. I knew that the part for me was, in the British version, his name was Keith. And I was like that. I get that comedy. So I went in to this big call, and I read the role of Stanley as though I were Kevin. Oh, wow.
然后她把我转给了艾莉森·琼斯。我和她一起读了剧本，我得到了斯坦利这个角色的面试机会。我知道那不是适合我的角色。我知道适合我的角色是，在英国版里，他的名字叫基思。我就是那样。我懂那种喜剧。所以我参加了这次大型面试，我读斯坦利的台词时，表现得就像我是凯文一样。哦，哇。
So smart. Brian. Well, or it could have been a disaster. It could have been like, what is this? But, right. So I went. I was there at the same time Oscar Nunez was there and Leslie David Baker were there. I can't remember who all else, but I know that they were there.
太聪明了。布莱恩。嗯，或者那可能是一场灾难。它可能看起来像，这是什么鬼？但是，对吧。所以我去了。我和奥斯卡·努涅斯以及莱斯利·大卫·贝克同时在那里。我不记得还有谁了，但我知道他们在那里。
And so I did it. They said, thank you. And I left and thought, well, that was a failed experiment. And Allison Jones ran down the hall. She said, hey, you know, they actually want to look at this other character. And in my head, I went, bingo. And went in, read that. And that's how it happened.
所以我做了。他们说，谢谢。我离开了，心想，好吧，那是一次失败的实验。艾莉森·琼斯跑过走廊。她说，嘿，你知道吗，他们其实想看看这个其他角色。我脑子里想，宾果。然后进去，读了那个角色。事情就是这样发生的。
But you never said, Allison, I think I'd be a better fit for Kevin. Would you give me a shot at it? You just took this risk of reading Stanley like Kevin. Yes. Because, well, because again, I was. totally unknown, right? I didn't have the experience. I mean, now, of course, that's what I would do. But yeah, no, I didn't. I was, you know, happy to have an opportunity. You know, I had just moved to Los Angeles a few months before. Wow. Yeah, I knew that. I knew that. Because the first day
但你从来没说过，艾莉森，我觉得我更适合凯文。你能给我个机会吗？你只是冒着风险把斯坦利读得像凯文。是的。因为，嗯，因为再说一次，我完全不知名，对吧？我没有经验。我的意思是，现在，当然，我会那么做。但是的，不，我没有。我当时，你知道，很高兴能有机会。你知道，我几个月前才搬到洛杉矶。哇。是的，我知道。我知道。因为第一天
on set when we got to know each other, just briefly chatting, Oscar and I were sort of commiserating about how many years we'd been out here plugging away. And we're like, what about you, Brian? And he was like, I've lived here like eight weeks. We're like, what? I've been here two months. We're like, holy crap. Well, the thing that's like standing out to me are the number of people who came in for a role other than the one they wound up in. Angela, you first came in for Pam. But then also, Ed originally auditioned for Michael Scott. John was brought in to play Dwight. Yeah. And Raine auditioned for Michael Scott as well. I know. That's crazy. A lot of people.
在片场，当我们互相认识时，只是简单地聊了聊，奥斯卡和我都在感叹我们在这里摸爬滚打了多少年。我们问，你呢，布莱恩？他说，我住在这里大概八周了。我们说，什么？我在这里待了两个月。我们说，天哪。嗯，让我印象深刻的是，很多人来面试的角色并不是他们最终得到的那个。安吉拉，你最初是来面试帕姆的。但还有，艾德最初试镜的是迈克尔·斯科特。约翰被带进来演德怀特。是的。雷恩也试镜了迈克尔·斯科特。我知道。太疯狂了。很多人。
Yeah. I feel like on the set, you and John Krasinski were pretty good buds. Yeah, you guys became good pals. And the four of us, I would say, you and John, me and Angela, we could often be found in John Krasinski's trailer during lunchtime. You guys had some heated Madden football matches, I mean, for years. Now I hear people talking about, you know, what a family we were and the, and the, and the crew and the cast, and all of that, by the way, is true.
是的。我觉得在片场，你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基是很好的哥们。是的，你们成了好朋友。我们四个，我会说，你和约翰，我和安吉拉，午餐时间经常能在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的拖车里找到我们。你们进行了几场激烈的《麦登橄榄球》比赛，我的意思是，持续了好几年。现在我听到人们谈论，你知道，我们是一个多么像家庭的团队，还有剧组和演员，所有这些，顺便说一句，都是真的。
But then undoubtedly someone will mention, like, lunch, and at lunch, you know, you would sit with this. I didn't sit with anyone. John Krasinski and I played Madden football in his trailer essentially every single. That's right. It was weird. We could hear you guys. If we walked past the trailer at lunch, you could literally hear like, oh, come on! Sometimes you would let rain play, but it seemed like begrudgingly.
但毫无疑问，有人会提到，比如，午餐，在午餐时，你知道，你会和这个人坐在一起。我没和任何人坐在一起。约翰·卡拉辛斯基和我在他的拖车里基本上每天都在玩《麦登橄榄球》。没错。这很奇怪。我们能听到你们的声音。如果我们午餐时路过拖车，你真的能听到像，哦，拜托！有时你会让雷恩玩，但看起来很不情愿。
You'd be like, oh, I guess we have to let someone else play. But it was the two of you, and I would like to know, are you willing to go on record and say who was better? Because I have a memory of who was better. Who do you think was better? I, well, if I say that we were even, that sounds like I'm hedging. but I do, we kind of, we both had teams that if we were allowed on that day to play those teams, the other person couldn't beat us. Mine, weird, I wasn't a fan, was the Chargers. And so, this is all great.
你会说，哦，我想我们得让别人玩了。但那是你们两个，我想知道，你愿意公开说谁更厉害吗？因为我记得谁更厉害。你觉得谁更厉害？我，嗯，如果我说我们平手，那听起来像是在推诿。但我确实，我们都有各自的球队，如果那天允许我们用那些球队玩，对方就赢不了我们。我的，奇怪的是，我不是粉丝，是闪电队。所以，这一切都很棒。
It called it the Gates play. Listen, if you ever play Old Madden and Antonio Gates in the scene, it's a touchdown every time. So, yeah, there's a pro tip for you, old badden players. Yeah, that's what I would say. He would get mad when he lost. I will say that. He would get way more mad than I would. Oh, yeah, and then grumpy.
它叫“盖茨战术”。听着，如果你玩老版《麦登》，安东尼·盖茨在场上，每次都是达阵。所以，是的，这是给你们这些老《麦登》玩家的专业建议。是的，我会这么说。他输了会生气。我会这么说。他会比我生气得多。哦，是的，然后变得脾气暴躁。
Grumpers. Because I was going to say, Brian, I think you were the better player. My memory from the lunches where I watched you guys play was you winning and then John getting pissed. That's what you held on to. Well, I remember you guys doing the Dundra Mifflin Fantasy Football League, which is still going strong. I have been told this week's standings are that this week standings are that John is in fourth, rain is in fifth, and Brian, you are in ninth.
脾气暴躁。因为我本来想说，布莱恩，我觉得你是更好的玩家。我从午餐时看你们玩的回忆是，你赢了，然后约翰气坏了。这就是你记住的。嗯，我记得你们搞了邓德·米夫林梦幻橄榄球联盟，现在依然很火。我被告知本周的排名是，约翰排第四，雷恩排第五，布莱恩，你排第九。
So here's the thing. I played rain this week. And by the way, when you all hear this, it'll be, that stanza will be different. Spoiler alert. I lost a rain this week by a point, and it flipped everything. So, yeah, I'm in, I'm in trouble. But I think I'm four and four. Rain is, I think, five and three.
所以情况是这样的。我这周和雷恩玩了。顺便说一句，当你们听到这个的时候，排名会不一样。剧透预警。我这周输给雷恩一分，一切都变了。所以，是的，我有麻烦了。但我认为我是四胜四负。雷恩，我想，是五胜三负。
So, like, it literally flipped everything. I was going through our fan mail, Brian, and a frequently asked question was about your voice. Because you very much do not sound like Kevin in real life. and people were curious, how did you develop this voice for the character of Kevin? Well, look, I, okay, so going back, and my manager and I, who I'm still with now, all of these years later, we still have this joke. So the casting notice about Kevin was the following. And I know it's true, because I've said it so many times. the only thing remarkable about Kevin is that he is remarkably unremarkable.
所以，它真的改变了一切。布莱恩，我正在翻看我们的粉丝邮件，一个常见的问题是关于你的声音。因为你在现实生活中听起来一点也不像凯文。人们很好奇，你是怎么为凯文这个角色塑造这种声音的？嗯，看，我，好吧，回到过去，我和我的经理，直到今天这么多年后我依然和他在一起，我们仍然有这个笑话。所以关于凯文的选角通知是这样的。我知道这是真的，因为我说过很多次了。凯文唯一引人注目的地方就是他非常平庸。
And so our joke is always like my manager saying to Allison Jones and everyone, you've got to meet this guy. He is so unremarkable. He is just the most unremarkable. So that's really where it started, which again really came from the character of Keith in the British version. I was like a theater actor, right? Like, for me, the construction of character, that's what I feel like I did, right? So I wasn't really an improv guy.
所以我们的笑话总是像我的经理对艾莉森·琼斯和所有人说的那样，你一定要见见这家伙。他太普通了。他简直是最普通的人。所以这真的是从那里开始的，这再次真正源于英国版里的基思这个角色。我当时是个戏剧演员，对吧？对我来说，角色的构建，我觉得我就是这么做的，对吧？所以我真的不是个即兴表演者。
It was for me about the character. And so for me, it's not like putting on a voice, but it's really about the body, the way the body moves. I know this is where many people are turning off the show right now. Right now, you should see, Jen. I'm on the edge of my seat. You are speaking to her theater nerd heart. Yes. I love it.
对我来说，这是关于角色的。所以对我来说，这不像是在装腔作势，而是真正关于身体，身体移动的方式。我知道很多人现在正在关掉这个节目。现在，你应该看看，珍。我正坐在座位边缘。你正在对她的戏剧书呆子心说话。是的。我喜欢它。
I'm hearing you. You created your character in your body, and that body placement informed your voice. So it came from the whole body. It didn't start just in your throat. Correct. And the way of speaking sort of becomes sort of a manifestation of that, right? But for Kevin, my idea was, two things. One is that he's not aware of his size in space. So hence me like bumping into Angela.
我听到了。你在身体里创造了你的角色，那种身体姿态塑造了你的声音。所以它来自整个身体。它不仅仅是从你的喉咙开始的。正确。说话的方式某种程度上成了那种表现，对吧？但对于凯文，我的想法是，两件事。第一是他在空间里没有意识到自己的体型。所以这就是我撞到安吉拉的原因。
Yeah, that's why I'm laughing. There's no, that that was one thing. And the second thing was that if you imagine my torso, right, he didn't rotate his hips side to side. So if he needed to look in one direction, right, his whole body then would have to turn like shuffle step to go in in that direction. But let me be clear, there was a progression to the development of the character too, right? And so I get asked sometimes like, hmm, your voice kind of changed from, you know, season one and through the show. And so my justification was in season one, Kevin was very, very nervous and scared of the cameras. And so when the cameras were around, he retreated into his show. like a turtle. And then as he became more comfortable or became even friendly with some of the crew, more of his true personality came out.
是的，这就是我笑的原因。没有，那是其中一件事。第二件事是，如果你想象我的躯干，对吧，他不会左右转动臀部。所以如果他需要看向一个方向，对吧，他的整个身体就必须像拖着步子一样转过去。但让我说清楚，角色的发展也有一个过程，对吧？所以有时有人问我，嗯，你的声音从第一季到整个剧集好像变了。所以我的理由是，在第一季，凯文非常非常紧张，害怕镜头。所以当镜头在周围时，他退缩到自己的壳里。像只乌龟。然后当他变得更自在，或者甚至和一些剧组成员变得友好时，他真正的个性就显露出来了。
Oh. I like that. I like that too. I think that's very good. Well, listen, should we talk about this famous chili cold open? I mean, Brian, we have got to. I brought my Kevin's chili mug. I am here for it. I brought chili for lunch today. Did you really? I did, if you can believe it. That's how on Brayn's. brand we are today. So, so many people wrote in about this cold open, Brian. It is so beloved, as you know. But it is also only 36 seconds long. I clocked it. And here is how it is described on Dunderpedia, which I thought was kind of amazing. It says, the cold open with Kevin's Chili has become one of the iconic moments of the show. It takes a low status character, offer, him a high status moment and then mercilessly takes it away. People relate to the moment of
哦。我喜欢这个。我也喜欢这个。我觉得这非常好。好吧，听着，我们应该谈谈这个著名的辣椒冷开场吗？我的意思是，布莱恩，我们必须谈谈。我带了我的凯文辣椒杯。我就是为此而来的。我今天午餐带了辣椒。你真的带了吗？我带了，如果你能相信的话。这就是我们今天有多符合布莱恩的风格。所以，很多人写信询问这个冷开场，布莱恩。如你所知，它非常受欢迎。但它也只有 36 秒长。我计时了。这是邓德百科上对它的描述，我觉得这有点神奇。它说，凯文的辣椒冷开场已经成为该剧的标志性时刻之一。它选取了一个低地位的角色，给他一个高地位的时刻，然后无情地夺走它。人们与那种私下的尴尬时刻以及试图拯救无法挽救之物的绝望感产生共鸣。这一幕在喜剧和心碎之间摇摆。在 36 秒内。是的。你知道，人们一直来找我。那是最常被提到的时刻。对我来说，现在有几种人。有些人会说，天哪，那太搞笑了。我喜欢它。然后有些人会说，我没法看。它让我心碎。我为凯文感到难过。现在，我认为事实上，它介于两者之间。就像，我认为既有喜剧，也有心碎的时刻，我从来不知道。我的意思是，从来没法想象，那个独自拍摄、周围没有其他人的时刻会变成今天这样。
private embarrassment and the desperation of trying to rescue something that cannot be saved. The scene teeters between comedy and heartbreak. In 36 seconds. Yeah. You know, people come up to me all the time. That's the moment that more often than not is referred to. And there are now, for me, types of people. There are some people who are like, oh my God, that is so hilarious. I love it. And then there are people who say, like, I can't watch it. It breaks my heart. I feel so bad for Kevin. Now, I think in truth, it's somewhere in the middle. Like, I think that I think that there's both, I think, you know, there's some physical comedy, but I think with a heartbreaking moment, I never knew. I mean, never could have imagined that. that one moment that was shot alone with nobody else around would become what it has today.
好吧，我们收到了大量的粉丝邮件。我敢说是暴风雪。顺便说一句，这是珍娜的术语。她有几个。我创造了一些短语。我们都有，但粉丝邮件阵雨/暴风雪。粉丝邮件阵雨。关于拍摄这个，你能告诉我们什么？因为它只是一个画外音，配上你端着这大锅心爱的辣椒走上楼梯的动作。你把它带进办公室。我们被告知这是一个年度活动。
Well, we got a fan mail flurry of emails. I dare say Blizzard. By the way, this is Jenna terminology. She has a few. I've coined some phrases. We both have, but the fan mail flurry slash blizzard. Fan Melflary. What can you tell us about shooting this? Because it is just a voiceover with your action of carrying this big pot of beloved chili up some stairs. You're bringing it into the office. We're told this is an annual event.
你带来了你的辣椒。然后它洒得到处都是，你拼命想把它清理干净。你是怎么做到的？我现在对此感到非常自豪。实际的主要部分是一次拍成的。泼洒？那是我们听到的。一次拍成。
You've brought in your chili. And then it spills everywhere and you try desperately to clean it up. How did you do it? I'm tremendously proud of this now. The actual main portion was one take. The spill? That's what we heard. One take.
泼洒是一次拍成的。所以他们显然做了一些准备，对吧？因为这肯定会是一团糟。毫无疑问这会是一团糟。我们排练过它会怎么进行。显然，这一切都是为了让泼洒的那一刻看起来和感觉尽可能真实，对吧？而且它发生在，你知道，我们在节目中没有标记，但它发生在摄像机能够捕捉到的正确位置，对吧？
The spill was one take. So they had done obviously some prep, right? Because this was going to be a mess. There was no question this was going to be a mess. And we'd rehearsed it, how it was going to go. Obviously, it was all about the moment of spill having that look and feel as realistic as possible, right? And that it happened in the, you know, we didn't have marks on the show, but it happened in generally the correct place for the cameras to be able to pick that up, right?
所以菲尔·谢伊像秘密一样，像后台渠道会议一样来找我。他说，好吧，所以你要知道，我们只有三块地毯。所以我们不能，我们不能再多做几次了。而且地毯，以防发生意外，是从前门绕过，我们称之为帕姆的前台，一直到德怀特和吉姆的办公区。我的意思是，那是一大块地毯，复制了那里现有的地毯，他们铺上并固定好，让它看起来就像那是地毯一样。他们说他们有三块，就这样了。所以我们需要开始。所以我对很多人说过，这一切都是计划好的。
So Phil Shea came to me, like, kind of like a secret, like back channel meeting. And he says, all right, so just so you know, we only have three pieces of carpet. So we can't, we can't do any more than that. And the carpet, in case there was an accident, was from the front door around, let's call it, Pam's reception desk, all the way to the Dwight and Jim Clump. I mean, it was a huge piece of the carpet that replicated the carpet that existed there and that they laid down and tacked in and made it appear as though that was the carpet. And they said they had three pieces of it and that was it. So we needed to go. So what I have said to many people is that that was all planned for.
清理我并不是真的。那不是真的。没人知道会发生什么，因为我被染色了。就像我被带走，我的——你的手就像橙色的一样。我记得可能是我最后一次公开淋浴，但感觉淋浴间里有 14 个人，像剥皮一样脱掉衣服，递给我毛巾，想把它从我的眼睛、头发和所有地方弄出来。
Cleaning me wasn't really. That wasn't really. No one had any idea what would happen because I was stained. Like I was brought like my- Your hands were like orange. And I remember probably my last public shower, but there were like, it felt like 14 people in the shower with me, like peeling off clothes and handing me towels to get it out of my eyes and hair and everything.
但是的，泼洒的过程确实是一次拍成的。而且有味道吗？因为菲尔·谢伊说他们只是用了无数罐真正的辣椒。我的意思是，那是辣味辣椒。你那天晚上把头枕在枕头上时还能闻到辣椒味吗？我可以告诉你，他在晚餐时闻起来有味道。是的，我正要说这个。你得分享一下。
But yes, it was the actual spilling of it was one thing. And did it smell? Because Phil Shea said they just used a gazillion cans of actual chili. I mean, it was spicy chili. Did you like put your head on the pillow that night and still smell chili? I can tell you he smelled at dinner. Yeah, that's what I was about to say. You got to share that.
所以安吉拉、奥斯卡和我经常一起吃晚餐，就像，好吧，让我们稍微打扮一下。就像，让我们看起来像真正的人。脱掉我们的邓德·米夫林衣服，去吃顿好的晚餐。这个特定的夜晚，我们有，而且是提前几个月计划好的，我们要去比佛利山庄的 Mastroes。感觉是非常好的牛排馆。那很高级。我们没有在这些会计晚餐上胡闹。
So Angela and Oscar and I did regular dinners where it was like, okay, let's dress up a little. Like, let's look like real people. Take off our Dundermifflin clothes and let's go to a nice dinner. This particular night, we had, and it was planned for months ahead where we were going to Mastroes in Beverly Hills. It feels very nice steakhouse. That's very fancy. We did not mess around with these account and dinners.
是的。不，我们没有胡闹。所以，当然，因为那是我们拍摄这一幕的晚上。所以其他人可以早点离开，他们，你知道，安吉拉可以卷她的头发什么的。所以我出现了。这就是安吉拉有空闲时间做的事。如果我有机会去更高级的地方，我会卷我的头发。布莱恩知道。
Yeah. No, we did not mess around. And so, of course, because that was the night we were filming this. So everybody else got to leave early that they were, you know, Angela got to curl her hair or whatever. And so I show up. That's what Angela does with free time. If I get to go some more fancy, I'm curling my damn hair. Brian knows.
让我们为你发短信。就是这样。我，所以我出现了，知道奥斯卡是那个人，因为我觉得你和我稍微更，如果他在听，我不想伤害奥斯卡的感情，但总有一个海鲜塔。奥斯卡每次都点它，这很讨厌。它占据了整个人。一个三层高的海鲜塔。还有牡蛎。是的，整个，他得到整个，他就像，是的，我们应该点那个塔。
Let's text us for you. That's the thing. I, so I show up and know Oscar is the one, because I think you and I are a little more, I don't want to hurt Oscar's feelings if he's listening, but there's always a seafood tower. Oscar orders it every time it is obnoxious. It takes up the whole people. A three-tiered tower of like seafood. And like oysters. Yeah, the whole, he gets the whole, he's like, yeah, we should do the tower.
它上来的时候，像是有蒸汽或烟雾从上面冒出来，因为有太多的干冰和排场。是的。这是真的。所以我说，这是 100% 真实的。所以我坐下来，我的手，我无法不闻到辣椒味。所以现在，这里有一个让你倒胃口的谈话。你的指甲是橙色的，布莱恩，因为你从手上弄掉了一些，但我的记忆是你的手仍然染着这种奇怪的颜色，但你的指甲，别提了。它们是橙色的。完了。完了。所以，想象一下把手伸进蟹腿里，然后你把它带到嘴边，闻到的全是那种非常糟糕的罐装辣椒味，我们就这么说吧，嗯，是的，它大概
It comes like, and it's like steam or smoke. is coming off of it because there's so much dry ice and fanfare. Yes. This is true. So I said, this is 100% true. So I sit down and my hands, I couldn't not smell chilly. So now, here's an appetizing talk for you. Your fingernails were orange, Brian, because you had gotten it a little bit off your hands, but my memory was your hands were still tinted this weird color, but your fingernails, forget it. They were orange. Done. Done. So, imagine that going into a crab leg and then you bring it to your mouth and there's just you're smelling really bad canned chili let's just put it that way um yeah it was it was it was probably
大概有几天会有染色，但味道肯定至少持续了 24 小时。好吧，我还有另一个关于冷开场的问题，用各种文件试图清理辣椒是你在抓东西时的即兴发挥吗？我的意思是，那太棒了。我喜欢那种绝望感。文件夹。一旦我倒在地上，我就能玩一点，对吧？所以我只是开始尝试其他东西。看，有很多粉丝在看节目时爱上了凯文。我把这归功于每个人内心深处想要赢一次的渴望。
there was probably some tint for for a couple of days but the smell for sure at least 24 hours well i have another question about the cold open is it true that the choice to try to clean up the chili with various paperwork was an improvisation in the moment where you're grabbing stuff? I mean, that's amazing. I love the desperation. The folders. Once I was on the ground, I got to play a little, right? And so I just sort of started trying other things. And look, there are a lot of fans who have fallen in love with Kevin to watching the show. And I attribute that to everyone's innate desire to win one.
是的。而且找到那些小小的成功是多么困难。布伦特·福雷斯特也说，他认为他们有大约八分钟你倒在辣椒里的镜头。八分钟。想想看，伙计们。八分钟是很长的时间。在辣椒里打滚。那很多。
Yes. And how difficult it is to find those little successes. Brent Forrester also said that he thinks they have about eight minutes of footage of you on the ground in the chili. Eight minutes. Think about that, you guys. Eight minutes is a long time. to be rolling around in some chili. It was a lot.
我知道我尝试了各种滑倒，人们觉得那很有趣。我记得尝试过那个。但你必须记住，再说一次，我记得站在监视器旁，当衣服开始从我身上脱下来看它时，对吧？再说一次。
I know that I tried a variety of slips, which people thought was funny. I remember trying that. But you have to remember, again, I remember standing by a monitor as like clothes were beginning to be taken off me to watch it, right? And again.
哦，是的，因为你可以那样做。你可以，比如，倒带磁带看回放，决定我们拍到了没有。正确。他们并没有每天都使用这种功能。但在一个需要，你知道，会有巨大重置的大场景中。是的。所以我记得甚至，你知道，看着它，我感觉很好，但我感觉很好并不重要。
Oh, yeah, Because you could do that. You could, like, rewind the tape and watch it back and decide, did we have it or not. Correct. They didn't use that capability on a daily basis. But on a major scene where you needed to, you know, there was going to be a huge reset. Yeah. And so I remember even, you know, watching it and me feeling good about it, but me feeling good about it doesn't really matter.
对。我记得走进淋浴间，不知道是否，你知道，因为对吧，拉弗恩和黛比是很棒的发型和化妆师。就像，她们都站在旁边准备尝试完全重置我再来一次。而且，你知道，她们显然有多个，你知道，同样的服装，等等。所以，是的，我记得那一刻，就像，拜托，拜托，我想我们拍到了。我想我们搞定了。好吧，布莱恩，我们也问每个人这个问题。你离开时从片场带走了什么？
Right. And I remember going into the showers, not knowing if, you know, because right, like Laverne and Debbie are great hair and makeup people. Like, they're all standing by ready to try to totally reset me to go again. And, you know, they had obviously multiple, you know, of the same outfit, et cetera. So, yeah, I remember that moment about like, please, please, I think we have it. I think we're good. All right, Brian, we also ask everyone this question. What did you take from the set when you left?
嗯，我带了几样东西，对吧？所以我带了文凭，凯文的，或者结业证书。所以我在节目里的第一个笑话，当凯文被迈克尔·斯科特描述时，他说了一些类似的话，他不是个伟大的会计，但是个相当不错的艺人。他们切到了一个 B 卷镜头，我拿着我的巨型铅笔，它在那之后的所有年里都放在我的桌子上，大多数人不知道那是个存钱罐。它还是空的。但我带走了那个，我带走了我的名牌。而且我……
Well, I took a few things, right? So I took the diploma, Kevin's, or certificate of completion. So my first ever joke in the show, when Kevin is described by Michael Scott, he says something like, He's not a great accountant, but a pretty good entertainer. And they cut to a B-roll shot with me with my giant pencil, which sat on my desk then for all the years, which most people don't know is a piggy bank. It's still empty. But I took that, and I took my nameplate. And I...
你有一个名牌？这么多年？我没意识到你有一个名牌。我有一个名牌。我不知道。我没有名牌。嗯，疯狂的事情是这样的。上面写着凯文吗？
You had a nameplate? All these years? I didn't realize you had a nameplate. I had a name plate. I didn't know that. I didn't have a nameplate. Well, here's the thing that's crazy. Does it say Kevin?
马龙？这是疯狂的事情，对吧？我的桌子在办公区。你甚至看不到它。不，它对着我。就像，为什么我需要它对着我？提醒你你的名字。因为这不是宣布的，你知道，通常你有一个名牌。
Malone? And here's the crazy thing, right? My desk was in a clump. You couldn't even see it. No, it faced me. Like, why would I need it faced? To remind you your name. Because it's not announced, you know, usually you have a nameplate.
就像如果你有一个办公室，有人走进来，他们可以立即看到你的名字。就像如果你去银行，就像，哦，这是苏西·马歇尔。嗨，苏西。不，那是一个对着我放了 10 年的名牌。这毫无意义。在一块玻璃后面。在它后面，是的。
Like if you have an off. office and someone walks in, they can see immediately what your name. Like if you go into a bank, it's like, oh, this is Susie Marshall. Hi, Susie. No, it was a nameplate that faced me for 10 years. It makes no sense. Behind a piece of glass. Behind it, yes.
不，我是在说，你必须坐在我的腿上才能看到名牌。这就是为什么我们不知道我们有一个。这毫无。不，我知道没有那回事。所以，是的，我带走了名牌。我带走了铅笔，我带走了 M&M 豆罐。是的。我喜欢那个。
No, what I'm saying is you would have to sit in my lap to see the nameplate. This is why we didn't know we had one. It makes no. No, I know there was no thing. So, yeah, I took the nameplate. I took the pencil, and I took the jar of Eminemes. Yes. I love that.
这太棒了。和你谈话真是太美妙了，布莱恩。是的，谢谢你让我们采访你。你以采访别人为生。现在你出了一本书。告诉我们你的书。《欢迎来到邓德·米夫林》。我的意思是，我们赶在假期前出版了。
This has been so awesome. It's been so wonderful to talk to you, Brian. Yeah, thank you for letting us interview you. You make your living interviewing people. And now you have a book out. Tell us about your book. Welcome to Dunder Mifflin. I mean, we're out in time for the holidays.
这是假期购物的最佳时刻。没错。听好了。这是长筒袜里的礼物材料。布莱恩，我见过这本书。你没法把那本书塞进长筒袜里。嗯，它很厚。那是她说的。
This is prime holiday shopping moment. That's right. Listen up. This is stocking stuff or material. Brian, I've seen the book. You're not getting that book into a stocking. Well, it's thick. That's what she said.
就是这样。这是一份厚礼。确实。有两个 C。好吧。好的。好的。就是这样。
There you go. It's a thick gift. It is. With two seas. All right. Okay. Okay. There we go.
告诉我们关于它的事。《欢迎来到邓德·米夫林》。它是，天哪，现在几年了，我一直在，我一直在，致力于构建《办公室》的完整口述历史以及发生了什么。对我来说，具体来说，它是关于一个问题，对吧？这个问题非常简单，我们播出时是一个大节目，对吧？在我们播出的绝大部分时间里，我们是 NBC 排名第一的剧本节目。但正如你们所知，后来发生了什么，你们播客的成功，巨大的成功，节目现在比以往任何时候都要大得多。
Tell us about it. Welcome to Dundermifflin. It is, you know, gosh, now a couple of years, I have been, I have been, working on constructing a full oral history of the office and what happened. And specifically for me, it was about a question, right? And the question was, very simply, we were a big show when we were on, right? We were the number one scripted show on NBC for most of the time that we were on the air. But what has happened since, as you all know, the success, the huge success of your podcast, that the show is so much bigger now than it ever was.
我的问题是，为什么现在，距离我们拍摄最后一幕已经七、八年了？为什么这个节目现在是世界上无可争议的观众冠军？为什么看这个节目的人比看任何其他节目的人都多？所以对我来说，这是关于回到过去看看发生了什么。为什么？为什么会这样？是关于演员阵容的构建吗？是关于瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫钱特最初选择的美学，并通过格雷格·丹尼尔斯和肯·夸帕斯传达的吗？所以这真的是关于发生了什么的宏观版本。所以我对这本书超级兴奋和自豪。
And my question was, why now, seven, eight years since we've filmed a scene? Why is this show now the undisputed champion of viewers in the world? Why are more people watching this show than any other show? And so for me, it was about going back to look at what happened. Why? Why did this happen? Was it about the construction of the cast? Was it about the aesthetic that was chosen originally by Ricky Jervais and Stephen
迫不及待了。那是一个概述吗？它像是一个采访集，就像你的播客《办公室口述历史》那样吗？
Merchant and through Greg Daniels and Ken Quappas? So it's really sort of a macro version of what happened. So I'm super excited and proud of the book. and can't wait. And is that like an overview? Is it like a collection of interviews, like from your podcast, the oral history of the office?
它什么都有点。是的，它确实回溯并追踪了我试图回答这个问题的旅程。所以它也涉及今天以及节目的遗产。但我回到了斯克兰顿，像个真正的记者，
It's a little bit of everything. Yeah, it really goes back and traces my journey of me attempting to answer this question. So it goes into today as well and the legacy of the show. But I went back to Scranton, like a real journalist,
回到了斯克兰顿，见了很多我们在那里的老朋友，谈论，你知道，节目是如何直接受到他们的影响，以及节目是如何真正改变了那个城镇。所以这是一个，这是一个，这是一个，这是一个，这是一个全面的观察，但我认为，我认为，我认为，我认为，我会确保你得到一本。好吧，谢谢。签名。我希望。我能得到签名版吗？是的。你没说 yes。是的。好的。布莱恩，你还有另一个公告。好吧，听着，我有一个播客，《办公室深度挖掘》，明年，1 月 4 日，即将到来，
went back to Scranton and met with a lot of our old friends from there talk about how, you know, the show was influenced directly from them and how the show has really changed that town. So it's a, it's a, it's a comprehensive look, but I think, I think, I think, I think, I think, I'll make sure you get a copy. Well, thank you. Signed. I hope. Do I get a signed copy? Yeah. You're not saying yes. Yes. Okay. Brian, you have another announcement. Well, listen, I have a podcast, The Office Deep dive, and next year, January 4th, coming up,
我将扩展并过渡到一个新的播客，《布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳的节拍之外》，一月份推出。所以我喜欢和《办公室》里的所有人交谈，对吧，进行冗长的讨论，但真正谈论的是其他媒体大多涵盖的时刻之间的时刻。所以从明年开始，我将和你们最喜欢的其他电视明星交谈，比如《摩登家庭》、《干杯酒吧》、《宋飞正传》、《新鲜王子妙事多》，随便谁。我们将专注于这些明星生活中发生的重要时刻。节拍之外。我有一位法国导演告诉我，这对《办公室》非常适用，顺便说一句，你可以偷用这个，喜剧，真正的喜剧发生在节拍之外。所以对我来说，我想和人们谈论的时刻是发生在
I'm going to be extending and transitioning to a new podcast, off the beat with Brian Baumgartner coming in January. So I've loved talking to all the folks on the office, right, having lengthy discussions, but really talking about the moments in between the moments that is mostly covered by other press. So starting next year, I'm going to be talking to your other favorite stars from TV, like Modern Family, Cheers, Seinfeld, Fresh Prince of Bel Air, whoever. And we're going to be focusing on important moment in these stars' lives that happened. off the beat. I had a French director who told me, which is really applicable to the office, by the way, you can steal this, that comedy, real comedy happens off the beat. And so for me, the moments that I want to talk to people about are the moments that happened in between
重要时刻之间的时刻，那些导致每个人都在报道的那些大时刻的事情。所以我超级兴奋能从《办公室》扩展出去。显然，我们会继续关注《办公室》，但会和你们最喜欢的其他电视节目里的人交谈。那太棒了，布莱恩。我们迫不及待想听了。那会很棒。非常感谢。
the important moments, the things that lead to those big moments that everyone else is covering. So I'm super excited to be expanding from the office. Obviously, we'll keep checking in with the office, but talking to people from your other favorite television shows. That is fantastic, Brian. We can't wait to hear it. It's going to be great. Thank you so much.
我很感激。好吧，轰炸机们，我们非常爱你。再次感谢布莱恩，感谢这次慷慨的采访。谢谢你来《办公室女士》。非常感谢你们邀请我。祝贺你们所做的一切。我为你们俩感到非常、非常高兴和自豪，我非常、非常爱你们。爱你，B。他要让我哭了。我知道。我们爱你，布莱恩。嗯，我喜欢我们的采访
I appreciate it. All right, Bombers, we love you so much. Thank you again, Brian, for this generous interview. Thanks for coming on office, ladies. Thank you so much for having me. Congratulations to everything that you guys are. doing. I'm so, so happy and proud of you both, and I love you so, so much. Love you, B. He's going to make me cry. I know. We love you, Brian. Well, I loved our interview
和布莱恩的采访。我喜欢每一秒。这只是让我怀念我们所有人聚在一起的时光。现在，听着，在我们和布莱恩的采访中，我们谈了很多关于他的辣椒冷开场，但如果你能相信的话，关于它我们还有几件事可以分享。首先，它是由亚伦·舒尔写的，最初应该是他剧本《迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司》的冷开场。但它最终被剪掉并移到了《休闲星期五》。而且我们的剧组为了完成这个辣椒特技必须做很多工作。是的，我们的第一助理导演拉斯蒂·马哈茂德在一次采访中分享了，我觉得这太有趣了，珍娜。他说，当他读到一个有非常多道具的冷开场剧本时，他会立即感到
with Brian. I loved every second. It just made me miss us all hanging out. Now, listen, in our interview with Brian, we talked a lot about his chilly cold open, but if you can believe it, there are a few more things that we can share about it. So first of all, it was written by Aaron Scher, and it was originally supposed to be the cold open for his script, Michael Scott Paper Company. But it ended up getting cut and moved to casual Friday. And there was a lot that our crew had to do to pull off this chili stunt. Yes, our first assistant director, Rusty Mahmood, shared in an interview, and I found this so interesting, Jenna. He said, when he would read a script that had a cold open that was very prop intensive, it was immediately
压力很大。哦，不。所以当其他人在笑的时候，他能欣赏，对吧，幽默，但他也看到了背后要付出的艰苦努力。当然。他说他对于这一幕的思考过程特别在于，我们如何在不毁掉办公室的情况下泼洒一大桶辣椒？所以他们开了一个道具会议。他们必须讨论桶有多大，它会掉在哪里。所有布莱恩谈到的东西。是的，兰迪补充说，从实际角度来看，他们特意把这作为本周的最后一场戏。这样他们基本上可以在周一之前有时间清理它。对，因为他们不知道会有多糟糕。天哪。所以即使他们做了所有这些排练，他们的担心是这是一桶辣椒掉下来。它可能会以某种
stressful for him. Oh, no. So while everyone else is laughing, he could appreciate, right, the humor, but he also saw the hard work that was going to go behind it. Sure. He said his thought process in particular for this moment was, how do we drop a huge vat of chili without destroying our office? So they had a prop meeting. They had to discuss how big the vat was, where it was going to fall. All of stuff that Brian talked about. Yeah, Randy added that on a practical note, they deliberately made this the very last scene of the week. So they could have time to clean it up before Monday, basically. Right, because they didn't know how bad it was going to be. Oh, my gosh. So even though they had done all these rehearsals, their concern was that it's a vat of chili falling. It could hit at some
奇怪的角度撞击并溅到墙上。溅到所有东西上。是的。而且，我的意思是，想想那个药球，除非你在接缝处和正确的位置击中它，否则它永远不应该爆裂。果然，那发生了。所以他们必须为一切做好准备。兰迪还提到，凯文端着辣椒桶走上楼梯的那部分，他们不能承受泼洒。在楼梯上。
weird angle and splatter across the wall. All over everything. Yeah. And, I mean, just like think about the medicine ball that was never supposed to pop unless you hit it on the seam and the right space. And sure enough, that happened. So they had to be prepared for everything. Randy also mentioned that the part where Kevin's just carrying the vatichilli up the stairs, they could not afford for a spill. On the staircase.
是的。哦，天哪。所以对于那个，他们用一些水槽装满了锅。袋子，因为他们确实仍然希望它感觉很重。对。而且布莱恩，如你所知，受过专业训练的演员。是的。他多次说过，他不想假装端着很重的东西。
Yes. Oh, gosh. So for that, they filled the pot with some sink. bag because they did still want it to feel heavy. Right. And Brian, as you know, classically trained actor. Yes. He has said numerous times that he didn't want to fake carrying something heavy.
是的。天哪。所以为了那个，他们往锅里装了一些水槽里的东西。袋子，因为他们还是想让它感觉很重。对。而且布莱恩，如你所知，是受过古典训练的演员。是的。他多次说过，他不想假装搬运重物。
He wanted to feel carrying something heavy. Yes. And then another little cheat they did was with the actual pot of chili. They thought they could make a fake bottom on that vat so that like the bottom third was filled with thumb. and then there would be a fake bottom to the pot, so it wouldn't be as much chili falling out. That would help avert a disaster. Yeah.
他想感受一下搬运重物的感觉。是的。然后他们还耍了另一个小花招，就是那个辣椒锅。他们想在那个大锅底部做一个假底，这样底部三分之一装的是填充物，然后锅里有一个假底，这样就不会洒出那么多的辣椒了。这有助于避免灾难。是的。
Also, Rusty said that if they filled the whole thing with chili, it probably would have weighed over 50 pounds. So they needed something that Brian could carry through the door. And in the end, Rusty shared that it took about an hour to clean everything up and replace that carpet. One last thing I would like to share about this chili cold open is some of the dialogue that was part of Kevin's voiceover that didn't make it in. Oh! This is in the shooting draft.
另外，拉斯蒂说如果他们把整个锅都装满辣椒，重量可能会超过50磅。所以他们需要一些布莱恩能搬过门的东西。最后，拉斯蒂分享说，清理所有东西并更换地毯大约花了一个小时。关于这个辣椒开场，我还想分享最后一件事，那就是凯文画外音中一些没被采用的台词。哦！这在拍摄剧本里。
And I guess it would have bought him more time to do different things. Sure. Right? But they trimmed it down. Here are two things Kevin would have said. Spiciness is to chili, what makeup is to a woman. I don't need a lot. I've got a sexy pot of chili.
我想这会为他争取更多时间去做别的事情。当然。对吧？但他们把它删减了。以下是凯文原本会说的两句话。辛辣之于辣椒，就像化妆之于女人。我不需要太多。我有一锅性感的辣椒。
Okay. And now for the next one, parsley is a tricky little beast, but it will tolerate some shade. Hmm. I don't know. It's just funny to me. And you know, the writer Anthony said they had so much fun coming up with spices and ingredients for Kevin to say. Oh, yeah. I'm sure that was a fun writer's room pitch. Well, now I think we can get into this episode, which has a question. great opening that was so fun to shoot. Pam and Ryan come in with this big circle thing with a question mark on it. Wait, wait, hold up. Before they even come in, you have got to go to one minute, one seconds. There is no plant at reception. Well, of course not. No plant. We know who's responsible for those plants and it's Pam. I know, but Aaron hasn't brought anything in. I just couldn't believe it. It didn't even feel like front reception to me.
好的。现在是下一句，欧芹是个棘手的小东西，但它能忍受一些阴凉。嗯。我不知道。这对我来说只是很有趣。你知道，编剧安东尼说，他们想出让凯文说的香料和配料时玩得很开心。哦，是的。我敢肯定那是一个有趣的编剧室提案。好吧，现在我想我们可以进入这一集了，这一集有一个问题。很棒的开场，拍摄起来太有趣了。帕姆和瑞恩带着这个上面有个问号的大圆圈进来了。等等，等等，停一下。在他们进来之前，你必须去看一分零一秒。前台没有植物。好吧，当然没有。没有植物。我们知道谁负责那些植物，是帕姆。我知道，但艾伦什么都没带进来。我简直不敢相信。这对我来说甚至感觉不像前台。
Oh, that means a lot. You're welcome. Also, can we please note Pam's khaki pants and tope kids? Is it tope? beige. Really? Mm-hmm. They're not white?
哦，那意义重大。不客气。另外，我们能注意一下帕姆的卡其裤和灰褐色吗？是灰褐色吗？米色。真的吗？嗯哼。它们不是白色的吗？
Nope. Scandalous. Very scandalous. As you were saying, they're holding this piece of paper with a big question mark on it. Who's behind it? Who is it? Who is it? Who is it?
不是。太离谱了。非常离谱。正如你所说，他们拿着这张写着大问号的纸。谁在后面？是谁？是谁？是谁？
Who is it? Well, it's someone trying to bust through. It takes him... several tries. I was cracking up at you and BJ, not Ryan and Pam, but I could see you and BJ when he was trying. There was real resistance. You guys were really like having to hold it steady. Well, people wanted to know, was it like scripted that he would have a hard time breaking through this paper, or is that just what happened? Yes, it was scripted. Director Brent Forrester actually shared that this idea was based on something that I
是谁？好吧，是一个试图冲破它的人。他花了……好几次尝试。我被你和BJ逗笑了，不是瑞恩和帕姆，但我能看到你和BJ在尝试的时候。有真正的阻力。你们真的就像不得不把它稳住。好吧，人们想知道，他很难冲破这张纸是剧本写的，还是只是发生了这种情况？是的，是剧本写的。导演布伦特·福雷斯特实际上分享说，这个想法是基于我
guess the writers had seen on YouTube of a high school cheerleading squad trying to bust through a paper banner, but they, it wouldn't rip and they end up in a pile or something. There's so many. There's so many. This clearly is a thing that happens. I have kind of witnessed this a little bit. Like live? Live, yes. And then sometimes what happens is the team is running behind the cheerleaders. Oh, no. I know. And then you hit that resistance and that, yeah. Yeah. Phil Shea made six of those circles for Steve to bust through. He used butcher paper, which is heavier than regular paper, so it would actually be kind of tough. What was the circle? Like a hula hoop or something? Yeah. We only had to do the scene twice, though. So there's four extra circles sitting backstage that day. Of course, Michael is going to announce conference room five minutes. Oh, he's been in the office for, 40 seconds, and he's already calling a conference room meeting.
猜编剧们在YouTube上看到的，一个高中啦啦队试图冲破纸横幅，但它们撕不破，最后他们堆成一团之类的。有太多了。有太多了。这显然是一件会发生的事情。我有点亲眼目睹过这个。现场吗？现场，是的。然后有时会发生的是，队伍在啦啦队员后面跑。哦，不。我知道。然后你遇到了那种阻力，然后，是的。是的。菲尔·谢为史蒂夫做了六个那样的圆圈来冲破。他用了牛皮纸，比普通纸更厚，所以实际上会有点难。那个圆圈是什么？像呼啦圈之类的吗？是的。不过我们只需要拍两次那个场景。所以那天后台有四个多余的圆圈。当然，迈克尔要宣布会议室五分钟。哦，他在办公室待了40秒，就已经在召集会议室会议了。
Conference room, five minutes. In this conference room, he really invites the employees to say whatever is on their mind. He wants an apology, desperately. And this starts for my character just a delightful storyline, which is every single person in the office loves casual Friday, but Angela Martin hates it. That tracks for me. And finds it inappropriate. It is also in this meeting where Michael is going to let me. let everyone know that Pam and Ryan are staying on in sales, and they get to keep the clients.
会议室，五分钟。在这个会议室里，他真的邀请员工说出他们心里的任何想法。他迫切地想要一个道歉。对于我的角色来说，这开启了一个令人愉快的故事情节，那就是办公室里的每个人都喜欢休闲星期五，但安吉拉·马丁讨厌它。这对我来说很合理。而且觉得它不合适。也是在这个会议上，迈克尔要让我……让每个人都知道帕姆和瑞恩继续留在销售部，而且他们可以保留客户。
And people are not happy about that. One of my favorite lines of the episode is when Andy says, I call foul, sir. Well, Michael says people can file their complaints into the trash can. The complaint department. Jenna, did you notice in this scene that Pam is completely covered by her purple sweater, and Phyllis is only in the plaid shirt. Mm-hmm. That was intentional because they don't want to mess up the reveal.
人们对此并不高兴。这一集中我最喜欢的台词之一是安迪说，我抗议，先生。好吧，迈克尔说人们可以把他们的投诉扔进垃圾桶。投诉部门。珍娜，你注意到在这个场景中，帕姆完全被她的紫色毛衣遮住了，而菲利斯只穿了格子衬衫吗？嗯哼。那是故意的，因为他们不想搞砸揭晓环节。
Yes, and it's a bit of a cheat because you have to imagine that just because the audience hasn't seen Pam and Phyllis standing in their identical outfits, surely Pam and Phyllis have seen one another as they went into the conference room. Exactly. They've been there for most of the morning. But that brings us to the kitchen where Pam and Phyllis discover. that they are, in fact, wearing the exact same outfit that they both liked on the mannequin at the mall. Pam says they got it at Boss Cove's at the Steamedown Mall. Mm-hmm. So you know I had to know.
是的，这有点作弊，因为你必须想象，仅仅因为观众没有看到帕姆和菲利斯穿着同样的衣服站在一起，帕姆和菲利斯肯定在走进会议室时见过对方。完全正确。他们整个上午大部分时间都在那里。但这把我们带到了厨房，帕姆和菲利斯发现。他们实际上穿着完全一样的衣服，那是她们俩在商场的模特身上都看中的。帕姆说她们是在斯坦镇商场的博斯科夫买的。嗯哼。所以你知道我必须知道。
Is it a real store? Is Bosco's a real store? And is it at the Steentown Mall. Well, let me tell you, Bosscoves is a real store, and there is one at the Steentown Mall. And I had to know a little bit about what this store is. Because they're very East Coast. I'd never heard of it, right? Me either.
那是一家真正的商店吗？博斯科夫是一家真正的商店吗？它在斯坦镇商场吗？好吧，让我告诉你，博斯科夫是一家真正的商店，斯坦镇商场里确实有一家。我必须了解一下这家店是什么。因为它们非常有东海岸特色。我以前从没听说过，对吧？我也没听说过。
On the Boscove's website, it says it is a family-owned department store for over 100 years, and it is, in fact, America's largest family-owned department store. Oh! Yes, Jenna, are you ready for this? A little bit of background info on Boscoves. And this is on their website. At only 18 years old, Solomon Boscove left his family in Russia, immigrated to the United States in 1914. He settled in Reading, Pennsylvania. With a pack on his back and a few dollars he had,
在博斯科夫的网站上，它说这是一家拥有100多年历史的家族百货公司，而且它实际上是美国最大的家族百货公司。哦！是的，珍娜，你准备好听这个了吗？关于博斯科夫的一点背景信息。这在他们的网站上。年仅18岁时，所罗门·博斯科夫离开了他在俄罗斯的家人，于1914年移民到美国。他在宾夕法尼亚州的雷丁定居。背着一个包，带着他仅有的几美元，
he began peddling household goods to the farm families in the surrounding area. Like a door-to-door salesman? That's right. And he got a reputation of being very fair and very honest. The business grew, his reputation grew. He was able to buy dry goods and provide merchandise, and the first Bosco's department store was established. And it's still going strong today.
他开始向周边地区的农场家庭兜售家居用品。像挨家挨户的推销员吗？没错。他以非常公平和诚实而闻名。生意越做越大，他的名声也越来越大。他能够购买干货并提供商品，第一家博斯科夫百货公司就此成立。而且它今天依然经营得很好。
Lady, hear me out. out. Next time we're in Scranton, we go to Boscoves at the Steemptown Mall and we buy matching outfits. Done. And then we go bowl and go to poor Richards. I mean, we have a lot of places to go. We got a lot of places to go. Well, we got a lot of mail about these matching outfits. So many questions on how they were chosen. And also, if I felt at all that this outfit was a little out of character for Pam, well, I reached out to Alicia, our wardrobe designer. for this episode, and she shared with me that this storyline was a very late addition to the script. She had very little time to figure out what this matching outfit will be.
女士，听我说。下次我们在斯克兰顿时，我们去斯坦镇商场的博斯科夫买配套的衣服。成交。然后我们去打保龄球，去波尔·理查兹。我的意思是，我们有很多地方要去。我们有很多地方要去。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这些配套衣服的邮件。关于它们是如何选择的有很多问题。而且，如果我觉得这套衣服对帕姆来说有点不符合角色，好吧，我联系了艾丽西亚，我们这一集的服装设计师。她和我分享说，这个故事情节是剧本中非常晚才加入的。她几乎没有时间去想这套配套的衣服会是什么。
She said she normally would have made something from scratch, because that's her. I mean, this woman is amazing at building clothing. Yeah. But because of time, she had to find existing pieces. So Alicia started by going to the stores where she would buy Phyllis's wardrobe. And she was really concerned about Phyllis feeling comfortable in this outfit. She shared that she had color palettes for all of our characters, and she looked at the color palettes for Pam and Phyllis, and she saw that we had a few overlapping colors.
她说她通常会从零开始制作，因为那是她的风格。我的意思是，这个女人在制作服装方面太棒了。是的。但因为时间紧迫，她不得不寻找现成的单品。所以艾丽西亚首先去了她会购买菲利斯服装的商店。她非常担心菲利斯穿这套衣服是否舒服。她分享说她为我们所有的角色都有调色板，她看了帕姆和菲利斯的调色板，她看到我们有几个重叠的颜色。
And our overlapping colors were mauve, mint, cocoa brown, navy, and purple. I would dare say that purple was an overlapping color for the majority. of the office. I think Alicia likes purple. Well, I had a purple breakdown of a whole scene. I think when we have Alicia on the podcast, we're going to ask her, what's your favorite color? Let's see if she says purple. I think she's going to say purple. So she said the first item she found was the plaid shirt. And she thought that was a good place to start. She said, also, our characters both tended to layer our clothes. And she thought, though, that there needed to be something that that wasn't too Phyllis or too Pam about it,
我们重叠的颜色是淡紫色、薄荷绿、可可棕、海军蓝和紫色。我敢说紫色是办公室里大多数人的重叠颜色。我觉得艾丽西亚喜欢紫色。好吧，我有一个关于整个场景的紫色崩溃。我想当我们请艾丽西亚上播客时，我们要问她，你最喜欢的颜色是什么？看看她会不会说紫色。我觉得她会说紫色。所以她说她找到的第一件单品是格子衬衫。她认为这是一个很好的起点。她说，而且，我们的角色都倾向于叠穿衣服。她认为，虽然，需要有一些不那么菲利斯也不那么帕姆的东西，
so she thought the little sweater shrug was another good crossover item. So that was her first choice of outfit. And then she bought it in both of our sizes. And then she found two other outfits that she thought might work. Well, this is all happening at 9 p.m. as the mall is closing the night before we had to shoot this. Oh, my gosh. That's how little time she had.
所以她认为那件小毛衣开衫是另一件很好的交叉单品。所以那是她选择的第一套衣服。然后她买了我们两个尺码的。然后她又找到了另外两套她认为可能可行的衣服。好吧，这一切都发生在晚上9点，就在我们必须拍摄的前一天晚上，商场快关门的时候。天哪。她只有这么少的时间。
She's like sprinting through the mall. Yes. So the next morning, Phyllis came in for her fitting, and Alicia said the plaid shirt was the clear winner. I came in for my fitting. I thought it was really cute. They altered the top a little bit for me. You might notice that my version is a little more fitted in the chest. I will say, looking back, this is not a fashionable outfit.
她就像在商场里冲刺一样。是的。第二天早上，菲利斯来试装，艾丽西亚说格子衬衫是明显的赢家。我来试装了。我觉得它真的很可爱。他们为我稍微改了一下上衣。你可能会注意到我的版本在胸部更合身一些。我会说，回想起来，这不是一套时尚的衣服。
It is not. Here's a thing. The plaid shirt is fine. It's the sweater. I don't know what you call that thing. It's not a shrug. Shrug? She called it a shrug.
确实不是。这里有一件事。格子衬衫还可以。是那件毛衣。我不知道你怎么称呼那个东西。它不是开衫。开衫？她称它为开衫。
Well, guess what? Just listen to the word shrug. Is that something you want to wear? Listen, back then, those shrugs were a thing. They were. You can look it up. And Capri pants were a thing. Oh, yeah.
好吧，猜猜怎么着？只要听听“开衫”这个词。那是你想穿的东西吗？听着，那时候，那些开衫很流行。确实是。你可以查一下。而且七分裤也很流行。哦，是的。
So I think maybe this outfit has just not held up great over time, really. But at the same time, Pam has never been a real fashion. forward gal. You know, she saw something on a mannequin. She tried it. I do like looking back, trying to imagine, like, how did Jim handle this back at the house when she's like, what do you think? Jim is like, it's great. It's different. How did what, have you had that moment with your husband? Okay. Jim wore a knit tie for years. He also bought his parents' house that had a clown mounted to the wall, a clown painting. I don't know that Jim has his finger on the pulse of fashion.
所以我认为也许这套衣服随着时间的推移并没有保持得很好，真的。但与此同时，帕姆从来都不是一个真正的时尚达人。你知道，她在模特身上看到了什么。她试了试。我确实喜欢回想，试着想象，吉姆在家里是怎么处理这件事的，当她说，你觉得怎么样？吉姆说，太棒了。很特别。你是怎么，你和你的丈夫有过那种时刻吗？好吧。吉姆戴了多年的针织领带。他还买了父母的房子，墙上挂着一个小丑，一幅小丑画。我不知道吉姆是否掌握着时尚的脉搏。
I guess you're right. I think he probably thinks Pam looks cute and everything. Hmm. Yeah. Lee has tried that for me when I'm like, okay, what do you think this outfit? He'll say, I think you look beautiful and everything. I'll say, well, obviously, I'm not getting this outfit. Because if I looked good, you'd just tell me I looked good.
我想你是对的。我想他可能觉得帕姆看起来很可爱之类的。嗯。是的。李试过为我这样做，当我说，好吧，你觉得这套衣服怎么样？他会说，我觉得你看起来很漂亮之类的。我会说，好吧，显然，我不会买这套衣服。因为如果我看起来很好，你只会告诉我我看起来很好。
He'd be like, no, I'm telling you, I think you're beautiful and everything. I think you're beautiful. I love you. And I'm like, okay, okay. Take a picture of me. I'm going to send it to Angela. I need a real opinion. This is true. I get whenever Jenna has to buy an outfit for anything, four years. This is like over a decade now, I get a little photo shoot spread texted to me. Yes. And you ask my thoughts. What would you say if I sent you this outfit? I would say skip the purple shruggy thing. Keep the shirt. Kacky pants. are fine. Mm-hmm. You know, given when this episode aired.
他会说，不，我是说，我觉得你很漂亮之类的。我觉得你很漂亮。我爱你。然后我说，好吧，好吧。给我拍张照。我要发给安吉拉。我需要一个真实的意见。这是真的。每当珍娜需要为任何事情买衣服时，四年了。这已经超过十年了，我会收到一连串的照片发给我。是的。然后你问我的想法。如果我把这套衣服发给你，你会说什么？我会说跳过那个紫色的开衫。保留衬衫。卡其裤。还可以。嗯哼。你知道，考虑到这一集播出的时间。
Okay. Fair enough. Well, Phyllis has a ton of sass in this episode. Oh my gosh. She tells Pam that she looks like a trout. She says, close your mouth, sweetie. You look like a trout. This is an epic insult.
好吧。有道理。好吧，菲利斯在这一集中有很多傲慢。天哪。她告诉帕姆她看起来像条鳟鱼。她说，闭上嘴，亲爱的。你看起来像条鳟鱼。这是一个史诗般的侮辱。
I am telling you, that is like amazing. Could you imagine saying to someone, you look like a trout? No. I think it's, I think, like, you know how in your mind you have like a fantasy argument with someone who you've always wanted to tell off, but maybe you're like me and you're not confrontational? Mm-hmm. This is fantasy moment. Close your mouth, sweetie. You look like a trout.
我告诉你，那真是太棒了。你能想象对某人说，你看起来像条鳟鱼吗？不。我觉得它是，我觉得，你知道在你的脑海里，你和某个你一直想教训的人进行了一场幻想争论，但也许你像我一样，不爱对抗？嗯哼。这是幻想时刻。闭上嘴，亲爱的。你看起来像条鳟鱼。
This is going to take us to a scene where Angela is complaining to Toby because Oscar has worn sandals and you can see his feet. Jenna, the scene was so much fun to do. I had so much fun yelling at Toby. And as I exit, I say, excuse me, oh, you're so educated, aren't you Toby? So trained to deal with the hysterical woman. I had an improvisation that made it in. I yelled, I don't want to look at his feet. That was improv.
这会把我们带到一个场景，安吉拉在向托比抱怨，因为奥斯卡穿了凉鞋，你可以看到他的脚。珍娜，这个场景拍起来太有趣了。我大声对托比喊叫玩得很开心。当我离开时，我说，打扰一下，哦，你受过很好的教育，不是吗，托比？受过如此训练来对付歇斯底里的女人。我有一个即兴表演被采用了。我大喊，我不想看他的脚。那是即兴表演。
Very good. Thank you. But you guys, let's think about this for a second. Do you really want to look at men's feet at work? Or on an airplane? You guys that were flip-flops on airplanes. I get it. Maybe it's your vacation. You're going somewhere tropical. Mm-hmm.
非常好。谢谢。但你们，让我们思考一下。你们真的想在工作中看男人的脚吗？或者在飞机上？你们这些在飞机上穿人字拖的人。我明白了。也许那是你的假期。你要去热带地方。嗯哼。
I don't know. When I see feet on a plane, it's weird. Do you take your shoes off on a plane? If you have on shoes and socks, will you take off your shoes if you have a long flight? I mean, it has to be a pretty long flight. I'm always cold, so I don't take my shoes off. You know what I bring? What? Slippers? Bring little, like, slipper socks. And so I'll take off my shoes and put on slipper socks.
我不知道。当我在飞机上看到脚时，很奇怪。你在飞机上会脱鞋吗？如果你穿了鞋子和袜子，长途飞行时你会脱鞋吗？我的意思是，那必须是相当长的飞行。我总是很冷，所以我不会脱鞋。你知道我带什么吗？什么？拖鞋？带那种，像，拖鞋袜。所以我脱掉鞋子，穿上拖鞋袜。
Just, I don't know. Just because I think it's rude to just be in, like, sock feet on a plane, too. Yeah. It's a small space. You don't wear your slipper socks into the bathroom, though. You put your shoes back on me. Oh, yes. Gross, right?
只是，我不知道。只是因为我觉得在飞机上光着脚也很粗鲁。是的。这是一个狭小的空间。不过你不会穿着拖鞋袜去洗手间。你得把鞋穿回去。哦，是的。恶心，对吧？
I'm certain men are pissing all over the bathrooms in the planes. Am I wrong? Am I wrong? I wipe that sucker down. I wipe it. I do, like, a cleaning before I go to the bathroom. For sure. Anyway, I'm just saying, is Angela?
我敢肯定男人们在飞机的洗手间里到处撒尿。我错了吗？我错了吗？我会把那个混蛋擦干净。我擦。我确实，在我去洗手间之前做一次清洁。肯定的。无论如何，我只是说，安吉拉是吗？
And just for the record, I do wash my hands when I exit an airplane washroom. Oh, thank God. I feel like I have to tell people now. Thank God. Every time. Well, listen. Even if I just pee. Listen, we all know that Angela is the office bitch.
顺便说一句，我离开飞机洗手间时确实洗手。哦，谢天谢地。我觉得我现在必须告诉人们。谢天谢地。每次。好吧，听着。即使我只是撒尿。听着，我们都知道安吉拉是办公室里的婊子。
But I think, I think, you know, maybe open-toed sandals for men on casual Friday, maybe I would agree with her. I didn't disagree with her. There you go. Well, this leads Toby to have this talking head where he reveals that he was. was in the seminary for a year? And there's a photo of him that we've never seen before? No. Randy shared that that was like a green screen photo.
但我认为，我认为，你知道，也许休闲星期五男士穿露趾凉鞋，也许我会同意她的看法。我没有不同意她。就是这样。好吧，这导致托比有了这个谈话头，他透露他曾在神学院待过一年？而且有一张我们以前从未见过的他的照片？不。兰迪分享说那是一张绿幕照片。
They took a picture at the church where Phyllis got married, and then they superimposed Paul onto that picture for that seminary photo. But he says that he dropped out to have sex with a woman named Kathy. He followed her to Scranton, got a job in HR, but now. they're divorced. Now, this is very much at odds with that deleted scene that you told us about from local ad where he says he worked in advertising for three years before joining Dunder Mifflin. I know. But that was deleted. So we decided if something was deleted, it didn't really happen in the world of the office. That's how we're saying it. Yes. I want you guys to know in the
他们在菲利斯结婚的教堂拍了一张照片，然后把保罗叠加在那张照片上，作为那张神学院的照片。但他说是为了和一个叫凯西的女人发生性关系而退学的。他跟着她去了斯克兰顿，在人力资源部找了份工作，但现在。他们离婚了。现在，这与你告诉我们的那个被删除的场景非常不符，在《本地广告》中，他说他在加入邓德·米夫林之前在广告业工作了三年。我知道。但那被删除了。所以我们决定如果某件事被删除了，它在办公室的世界里并没有真正发生。我们是这么说的。是的。我想让你们知道在
background of this talking head over Toby's shoulder, I saw Leslie eating. What? If you watch it, go to five minutes one second. I mean, Leslie had to be in the background for so long during all of these talking heads. He was such a trooper. I think he just got hungry. So Stanley's having a snack at his desk. It works. So next up, we're going to start to see a little bit of how Michael might be giving preferential treatment to Pam and Ryan.
这个谈话头的背景里，在托比的肩膀上方，我看到莱斯利在吃东西。什么？如果你看它，去五分零一秒。我的意思是，莱斯利在所有这些谈话头期间必须在背景里待那么久。他真是个勇士。我想他只是饿了。所以斯坦利在办公桌前吃零食。这行得通。所以接下来，我们将开始看到一点迈克尔可能如何给予帕姆和瑞恩优惠待遇。
Well, he goes and gets Ryan a soda. And then Jenna, what does he get Pam? He gives Pam a. A Fiji water. I am telling you, they were sponsoring the show. How are they not sponsoring the show? How many episodes now is this? This is the third Fiji water bottle spotting.
好吧，他去给瑞恩拿了苏打水。然后珍娜，他给帕姆拿了什么？他给了帕姆一瓶。斐济水。我告诉你，他们是在赞助这个节目。他们怎么不是在赞助这个节目？现在这是第几集了？这是第三次发现斐济水瓶了。
Once again, the label is facing away from camera, a deliberate move by Steve Karel as he sets it down. I asked Randy about it. Did you? Were we getting some secret Fiji dough? No. He says he has no idea why these Fiji waters are showing up on set. He said he was going to investigate it. But he said we did not have a deal with Fiji that he knows about.
再一次，标签背对着镜头，这是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔放下它时的一个刻意举动。我问过兰迪这件事。你问了吗？我们得到了一些秘密的斐济资金吗？没有。他说他不知道为什么这些斐济水出现在片场。他说他会调查一下。但他确实说我们没有他所知道的与斐济的交易。
However, he did say this, which I thought was really interesting. He said any time he ever is line producing something that takes place on a boat, they always use Fiji water because they don't roll. Yeah. Well, I feel like for me, this Fiji water on the set of the office is like that Starbucks coffee, remember in Game of Thrones? Yes. How there was the Starbucks coffee. I do remember. I'm like obsessed with like, what's up with this Fiji water?
然而，他确实说了这一点，我觉得非常有趣。他说任何时候他在线制作发生在船上的东西时，他们总是使用斐济水，因为它们不会滚动。是的。好吧，我觉得对我来说，办公室片场的这个斐济水就像那个星巴克咖啡，还记得《权力的游戏》吗？是的。那个星巴克咖啡是怎么出现的。我记得。我简直着迷于，这个斐济水是怎么回事？
Dwight is going to notice this special treatment that Michael is giving them. It's time for him to pass out a secret memo with invisible ink. Yes. Where did he get the invisible ink you might like to know? He says it's urine. Yeah, I'm guessing his urine. Yes. He's very frustrated because people don't know how to reveal the invisible urine message.
德怀特会注意到迈克尔给他们的这种特殊待遇。是时候让他分发一份带有隐形墨水的秘密备忘录了。是的。你可能想知道他从哪里得到的隐形墨水？他说那是尿液。是的，我猜是他的尿液。是的。他非常沮丧，因为人们不知道如何揭示隐形尿液信息。
Right. They're not savvy to the. invisible ink thing. Well, this got me wondering. Oh, no. I googled, can you use urine as invisible ink? Oh, my God. Really and truly, at the end of this podcast, I want to print our search history and put it
对。他们不精通隐形墨水那套。好吧，这让我感到好奇。哦，不。我谷歌了一下，你可以用尿液作为隐形墨水吗？哦，天哪。真的，在这个播客结束时，我想打印我们的搜索历史并把它
in a frame. Please do. Well, I'll have you know that, yes, urine can be used as invisible ink. and I discovered the most fascinating story of people using urine as invisible ink, and I'm going to share it with you now. Oh, okay. I'm reclining and getting my cup of tea. I'm settling in. All right. During World War II, there were a group of Polish prisoners who were taken to a Nazi death camp, and they used their urine as invisible ink to write letters detailing the horrific experiences that were going on at the camp. They were a group of young Polish girls and women who had been part of the Polish underground resistance to the Nazi regime.
装进相框里。请务必这样做。好吧，我会让你知道，是的，尿液可以用作隐形墨水。我发现了人们使用尿液作为隐形墨水的最迷人的故事，我现在要和你分享。哦，好的。我正靠着，拿着我的茶杯。我正安顿下来。好的。二战期间，有一群波兰囚犯被带到纳粹死亡集中营，他们用尿液作为隐形墨水写信，详细描述了集中营里发生的恐怖经历。她们是一群年轻的波兰女孩和妇女，曾是波兰地下抵抗纳粹政权的一部分。
And they were captured, they were imprisoned, and this group were called the Rabbits of Ravensbrook. because, and this is horrible, they were subjected to extreme medical experiments like rabbits. That's why they got this nickname. However, they were allowed to write letters to their families back home once a month. But the letters were heavily censored. One of these women remembered that when she was a child, her and her brother had read this series of books where people were writing messages. in invisible ink. So they used their urine to write these secret messages.
她们被俘虏，被监禁，这群人被称为“拉文斯布吕克的兔子”。因为，这太可怕了，她们像兔子一样被进行极端医学实验。这就是她们得到这个绰号的原因。然而，她们被允许每月给家里的亲人写一次信。但信件受到严格审查。其中一名妇女记得，当她还是个孩子时，她和她的兄弟读过一系列书，里面的人用隐形墨水写信息。所以她们用尿液写这些秘密信息。
And due to a reaction with the paper, the urine loses its color and becomes invisible, but then if you heat it up, it reveals what was written. And in her first letter to her brother, she wrote about these books that they read as kids, and he figured out the code and knew how to refer. the hidden messages. So they came up with this code with their families, which was, if the hidden messages were revealed, the families would send back a letter with a little piece of blue string. And that's how they knew if their messages were being received. So eventually, the contents of these letters and the horrific details of the camp were broadcast on the radio, and the camp was liberated by
由于与纸张的反应，尿液失去了颜色并变得隐形，但如果你加热它，它就会显示出写了什么。在她给兄弟的第一封信中，她写了他们小时候读过的那些书，他破解了密码，知道如何参考隐藏的信息。所以他们和家人想出了这个密码，那就是，如果隐藏的信息被揭示，家人会寄回一封信，里面有一小段蓝色的绳子。这就是他们知道信息是否被收到的方式。最终，这些信件的内容和集中营的恐怖细节在广播中播出，集中营被红军解放，
the Red Army, and the four women who wrote the letters all survived. Their letters were used as evidence to prosecute the guards. Wow. And 77 years later, these letters can still be read because 27 of them are still readable and on display in a museum in Lublin. Oh, my gosh. That is an amazing story. Amazing. I was completely riveted. I couldn't believe it. I couldn't. I couldn't believe it. Yeah, I'm just sort of speechless at the gravity of that story and how it's amazing. I think we should take a break. Yes. And when we come back, we find out yet a new detail of Toby. What is Toby? Toby's like this onion. We're just peeling layers back about him. We're back and there's this snippet of a scene. It's just a tiny moment where Toby is trying to get
写信的四名妇女都幸存了下来。她们的信件被用作起诉守卫的证据。哇。77年后，这些信件仍然可以阅读，因为其中27封仍然清晰可见，并在卢布林的博物馆展出。哦，天哪。那是一个令人惊叹的故事。令人惊叹。我完全被吸引住了。我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。是的，我有点被那个故事的严重性惊呆了，它是多么令人惊叹。我想我们应该休息一下。是的。当我们回来时，我们发现了托比的一个新细节。托比是什么？托比就像这个洋葱。我们只是在剥开关于他的层。我们回来了，有一个场景片段。这只是托比试图让奥斯卡拿走他的袜子的一小刻，他说它们是干净的。他本来要穿它们去排球练习。托比到底是谁？这个人是谁？他参加每周的排球比赛吗？就像，他打成人排球？好吧。我们收到了一些粉丝邮件，对这一点有几种理论。其中之一是，你知道，在公司野餐中会揭示帕姆喜欢排球。哦。他是在试图通过排球来给帕姆留下深刻印象吗？人们就是这么说的。那太可爱了。这场排球比赛即将到来。也许，他想和帕姆有共同点。哦，我喜欢那个。好吧，德怀特的秘密信息没有被收到。所以他要告诉所有不是帕姆或瑞恩的销售人员去仓库。我喜欢仓库里的那个场景。我觉得那是一个很棒的群戏场景。它让我想起迈克尔必须领导会议室场景时，每个人都让他偏离轨道。它比你在实际剧集中看到的要长得多。我真的希望你们能听到场景的其余部分。
Oscar to take his socks and he says they're clean. He was going to wear him to volleyball. practice. Who the heck is Toby? Who is this person? Was he in a weekly volleyball game? Like, he plays adult volleyball? All right. We got some fan mail that had a few theories on this. One of them being that, you know, it's going to be revealed in company picnic that Pam likes volleyball. Oh. Is he trying to get good at volleyball to impress Pam? That is what people were saying. That is so cute. That this volleyball game is coming up. And maybe, he wants to have something in common with Pam. Oh, I love that. Well, Dwight's secret message is not received. So he is going to just tell everybody who is a salesperson who isn't Pam or Ryan go down to the warehouse. I love the scene in the warehouse. I thought it was such a great ensemble scene. It reminded me of how when Michael has to lead a conference room scene and everyone keeps getting him off track. It was much longer than what you see in the actual episode. And I really wanted you guys to hear the rest of the scene.
谢谢大家的到来。现在，请每个人拿一支蜡烛。我们没有时间拿蜡烛。我想我们都在洗手间。跳过蜡烛。让我们直奔主题。这有多烦人，嗯？你是说今天发生的事情还是这个会议？
Thank you all for coming. Now, please, everyone take a candle. We don't have time for candles. I think we're all in the bathroom. Skip the candles. Let's cut to the chase. How annoying is this, huh? Do you mean what's going on today or this meeting?
不，显然会议上发生的事情并不烦人。只有其中的某些人很烦人。我可以带一支蜡烛回家吗？先生们，是时候把我们的球放在断头台上，正如他们所说。谁说过那样的话？地区表达。我说的是去找迈克尔，告诉他我们准备辞职了。哦，天哪，我不知道。
No, obviously what's happening at the meeting is not annoying. Only certain people in it are annoying. Can I take one of these candles home? Gentlemen, it's time to put our balls in the guillotine, as they say. Who has ever said that? Regional expression. I'm talking about going to Michael and telling him that we are ready to quit. Oh, boy, I don't know.
是的，德怀特，如果他拆穿我们的虚张声势怎么办？那我们就完了。因为如果我们什么都不做，那我们就失败了，失败不是一个选项。好吧，等等。让我们仔细想想。如果我们什么都不做，至少我们还有工作。如果我们什么都不做，我们就失败了，失败不是一个选项。好吧，说清楚，这是一个选项。
Yeah, Dwight, what if he calls our bluff? Then we are gone. Because if we do nothing, then we fail, and failure is not an option. Well, hold on now. Let's think this through. If we do nothing, at least we'll have our jobs. If we do nothing, we fail, and failure is not an option. Well, to be clear, it is an option.
在我的书里不是。我的书，封面是失败，不是一个选项。这是一个选项。在我的书里不是。字面上。什么书？你是什么？你写的吗？
Not in my book. My book, the cover is failure, is not an option. It is an option. Not in my book. Literally. What book? What are you? Did you write it?
我本来可以整天看那个。哦，那就是他们只是让我们继续用角色说话的时候。是的。这有点像长篇即兴练习。是的。好吧，当这一切在仓库里发生时，帕姆、瑞恩和迈克尔就像最好的朋友。他们在迈克尔的办公室里，他们对着这个照片拼贴画咯咯笑
I would have watched that all day. Oh, that's when they would just let us keep talking and character. Yes. It's sort of like a long form improv exercise. Yes. Well, while all this is happening in the warehouse, Pam, Ryan, and Michael are like best friends. they're up in Michael's office and they are giggling over this photo collage
迈克尔做的。我的意思是，瑞恩和帕姆在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司时互相憎恨。现在他们就像，就像他们是老战友之类的。我喜欢它。我喜欢这种动态。我们有一个来自阿德里安·M的粉丝问题。
Michael has made. I mean, Ryan and Pam hated each other at Michael Scott Paper Company. And now they're just like, it's like they're old war buddies or something. I loved it. I loved this dynamic. We had a fan question from Adrian M.
在迈克尔制作的记忆板上，照片是什么时候拍的？是在你们拍摄迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司剧集时完成的吗？是的，阿德里安，确实是。我们提前知道我们需要这些照片，因为兰迪·科德雷，他会提前拿到剧本
On the memory board that Michael makes, when were the photos taken? Was it done while you were filming the Michael Scott Paper Company episodes? Yes, Adrian, they were. We knew ahead of time that we were going to need these photos because Randy, Cordray, he would get the scripts early
这样他就可以预见视觉噱头、道具、地点以及所有进入策划剧集的事情。所以他知道对于这一集，我们需要这些照片。所以当我们拍摄《破产》时，我们拍了所有这些照片用于拼贴画。一个故事情节即将开始，我非常喜欢，珍娜，那就是吉姆和克里德。我非常喜欢它。我喜欢克里德表现得如此正常，以至于让你对他更加怀疑。我喜欢只要吉姆和克里德在一起的场景。正如你所知，约翰·克拉辛斯基总是，就像，完全崩溃
so that he could anticipate sight gags and props and locations and all these things that go into planning an episode. So he knew that for this episode, we would need these pictures. So while we were filming broke, we took all these pictures for the collage. A storyline is about to start that I loved. so much, Jenna, and it is Jim and Creed. I loved it so much. I loved how, like, Creed is being so normal that it makes you more suspicious of him. I loved just whenever Jim and Creed were in scenes together. And as you know, John Crosinski was always just, like, completely disintegrating
大笑。好吧，约翰喜欢和克里德演戏。所以我给克里德打了电话，因为我想，克里德，你在这一集中和吉姆有一个搞笑的故事情节，我提醒了他一下。我有拍摄剧本，我们一起过了一遍，珍娜。噢。我知道。让我们大笑的一件事是，克里德喜欢的一句台词，但没被采用。我想和你分享。所以场景开始时，克里德在角落里，在拍摄剧本中，吉姆拿了苏打水，
into laughter. Well, John loved doing scenes with Creed. So I called Creed, because I was like, Creed, you have this hilarious storyline with Jim in this episode, and I sort of reminded him of it I had the shooting draft and we went through it together, Jenna. Aw. I know. And one of the things that cracked us up, it was a line that Creed loved and it didn't make it in. I want to share it with you. So the scene starts that Creed is in the corner and in the shooting draft Jim gets a soda and
克里德说，你会对那个感到高兴的。嗯哼。吉姆说，嗨。然后克里德说，我来这里是为了休息一下。吉姆说，是的。这是被删掉的台词。克里德说，洗手间。我就是这么叫它的。
Creed says, you're going to be happy with that. Mm-hmm. And Jim says, hi. And then Creed says, I come here to take a break. And Jim says, yeah. here's the line that got cut. Creed says, the restroom. That's what I call it.
克里德把休息室称为洗手间。然后其余的是剧本写的。让我们谈谈这个故事情节，因为最终克里德会建议他们玩个游戏。是的。那个游戏将是国际象棋。嗯哼。不仅如此，克里德是一个非常好的国际象棋选手。是的。
Creed calls the break room, the restroom. And then the rest is scripted. Let's talk about this storyline, because eventually Creed is going to suggest that they play a game. Yes. And that game is going to be chess. Uh-huh. And not only that, Creed is a very good chess player. Yeah.
好吧，我和约翰·克拉辛斯基发短信讨论过这件事，因为我，我想知道，约翰是一个好的国际象棋选手吗？因为我知道你在联系克里德。所以我心想，我会得到约翰对此的看法。约翰说他知道怎么下国际象棋，但下得很差。好吧，这就是克里德说的。克里德说，是的，我会下国际象棋。我不是狂热爱好者，但我有基本技能。他说他实际上很期待和他的孙女们下国际象棋。哦。他想和她们分享。哦，你知道吗？李的父亲和我儿子下国际象棋。每次我抬头看到他们下棋，我的心都暖暖的。这就像他和爷爷做的事情。是的。然后最棒的是这个国际象棋跑动以吉姆的
Well, I texted with John Krasinski about this because I, I wanted to know, is John a good chess player? Because I knew you were reaching out to Creed. So I was like, I'll get John's side of this. John said he knows how to play chess, but very poorly. Well, this is what Creed said. Crete said, yes, I can play chess. I'm not an aficionado, but I have basic skills. And he said he's actually looking forward to playing chess with his granddaughters. Oh. He wants to share it with them. Oh, you know what? Lee's dad plays chess with my son. And it warms my heart every time I look over and see them playing chess. It's like his thing he does with his grandpa. Yeah. And then what's so fantastic is this chess runner ends with Jim's
谈话头结束，他说，我只是躲起来，直到所有这些事情过去，克里德在工作中下国际象棋。他赢了。我觉得我在描述我做的一个梦。是的，完全正确。所以听着，当帮派从仓库回来时，迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩就像，你们去哪儿了？他们声称他们去吃午饭了。我们就像，现在是清晨。你们午饭吃了什么？因为他们试图困住他们。
talking head that says, I'm just hiding out until all this stuff blows over with Creed playing chess at work. He's winning. I feel like I'm describing a dream I had. Yeah, exactly. So listen, When the gang comes back from down in the warehouse, Michael, Pam, and Ryan are like, where have you been? And they claim that they've been at lunch. And we're like, it's very early in the morning. What all did you have for lunch? Because they're trying to trap them.
安迪很快分享了这个。我吃了一个三文鱼沙拉配水，不加冰。我本来要喝苏打水，但服务员劝我不要喝。她叫弗洛。她有黑头发。立刻。这就像撒谎的艺术，好吗？就像，他认为通过分享大量的细节。
Andy very quickly shares this. I had a salmon salad with water, no ice. I was going to get a soda, but the waiter tucked me out of it. Her name was Flo. She had black hair. And immediately. this is like the art of lying, okay? Like, he thinks by sharing a ton of details.
对。那会让他看起来很正常。但让我告诉你，每当有人给我这样的回答时，我就想，嗯，可疑。是的，你想有细节，但你不能只是在开头一股脑地全部倒出来。不。迈克尔、帕姆和瑞恩就像，哦，好吧，如果你们，你知道，出去吃午饭了，那我想我们可以吃冰箱里的东西。是的。然后我们三个走进冰箱，开始吃每个人的
Right. That that's going to make him seem normal. But let me tell you, whenever someone gives me an answer like this, I'm like, mm, suspect. Yeah, you want to have the detail, but you don't just lay it all out at the top in one big blob. No. Michael Pam and Ryan are like, oh, well, if you guys, you know, went out to lunch, then I guess we can eat what's in the fridge here. Yes. And then the three of us go in the fridge and we start eating everybody.
午餐。请在花絮里看这个，你们。好吧，我记得。史蒂夫咬了一大口冷三文鱼片。你往嘴里铲土豆沙拉。那是鸡蛋沙拉，女士。哦，天哪，恶心。人们问，那真的是鸡蛋沙拉吗？是的。就像，它让我们笑。你满嘴鸡蛋沙拉笑得那么厉害，以至于有鸡蛋沙拉唾沫。太恶心了。哦，天哪。我记得它就像昨天一样。好吧，我们收到了来自尼基·S的粉丝捕捉，关于所有这些食物。她说，当迈克尔从冰箱里拿出销售人员的午餐时，他拿了一个绿色包装的三明治，
lunches. Please watch this in the bloopers, you guys. Well, I remember it. Steve took a huge bite out of a cold salmon filet. You're shoveling potato salad in your mouth. It was an egg salad lady. Oh, my God, gross. And people asked, was it really egg salad? It was. Like, it was making us laugh. You laugh so hard with a mouth full of egg salad that like there was like egg salad spittle. It was so gross. Oh, my God. I remember it like it was yesterday. Well, we got a fan catch from Nikki S. about all this food. She says, when Michael is taking the sales staff's lunches out of the fridge, he takes a green-wrapped sandwich,
它来自一个叫“Sheets”的加油站连锁店。他们以食物闻名，通常被称为MTO，代表“按需制作”。所以我查了一下，该地区确实有一连串叫“Sheets”的加油站，他们制作按需制作的食物。这是他们的广告。我饿死了。好吧，在Sheets停下来。在加油站买不到好吃的食物？真的吗？
and it's from a gas station chain called Sheets. They are known for their food, commonly called MTO, which stands for made to order. So I looked it up, and there is this string of gas stations called Sheets in the area, and they make made-to-order food. Here's their commercial. I am starving. Well, stop at Sheets. Can't get good food at a gas station? Really?
你不能只是同意吗？看，所以在那一刻，他们变成了驴。你知道那会做什么。对你和我。对不起。是的。它让你我看起来像个傻瓜。看？
You couldn't have just agreed. See, so in this moment, they've turned into donkeys. You know what that does. To you and me. I'm sorry. Yep. It makes an ass of you and me. See?
不要假设你在加油站买不到新鲜的按需制作食物。Sheets。被爱。是的。叮，叮，咚，叮，咚。所以这是……那是什么广告？那个广告里发生了什么？
Don't assume you can't get fresh made to order food at a gas station. She eats. Be over love. Yeah. Ding, ding, dong, ding, dong. So here's... What is that ad? What is happening in that ad?
那是两个人开车，他们想要一些食物。当他假设你在加油站买不到按需制作的食物时，他们就变成了驴。他们开始发出“嘿-哈”的声音。但这里有一件事让我想到，你还记得在《受伤》中迈克尔想要一些山药吗？是的。瑞恩说你在加油站买不到山药。是的。
It's two people driving in a car and they want some food. And as soon as he assumes that you can't get made to order food at a gas station, they turn into asses. And they start he-hawing. But here's the thing that got me that I was thinking, do you remember in the injury when Michael wants some yams? Yeah. Ryan says you can't get yams at a gas station. Yeah.
我只是想知道，Sheets卖山药吗？我能在我的三明治里加山药吗？我看了他们的菜单。似乎每个地点有时会有略微不同的项目。我找不到一个有山药的。所以我猜瑞恩还是对的。但Sheets，我认为你应该考虑，我不知道，对于所有的办公室粉丝，如果你开始在你的加油站卖山药，那可能会很受欢迎。
I just wonder, does sheets sell yams? Can I get a yam on my sandwich? I looked at their menus. It seems like each location sometimes has slightly different items. I could not find one that had yams. So I guess Ryan is still right. But Sheets, I think you should consider, I don't know, for all the office fans out there, if you started selling yams at your gas station, it might be a hit.
也许这是一个节日项目。是的，这是一个节日项目。我有一个问题要问Sheets。那面包是真的吗？因为那面包就像别克车那么大。我不知道。说真的，那面包有史蒂夫的头那么大。这是一个有趣的片段，布伦特在DVD评论中分享了整个
Maybe it's a holiday item. Yeah, it's a holiday item. I have a question for Sheets. Is that bread for real? Because that bread was like the size of a Buick. I don't know. Seriously, that bread was the size of Steve's head. Here's an interesting tidbit that Brent shared in the DVD commentary this entire
整个第三幕是在明迪、BJ、吉恩和李的编剧小组中在大约12小时内写出来的。哇。整个第三幕。我记得布伦特和我们分享，艾丽西亚也支持这一点，整个剧本是在最后关头完成的。就像，这是季终集。他们被耽误了。他们时间不够了。我们精疲力竭。
entire third act was written in a breakout pod of writers of Mindy, BJ, Gene and Lee in about 12 hours. Wow. Entire third act. I remember Brent sharing with us, and Alicia supports this, that this whole script came down to the wire. That, like, this is the end of the season. They're backed up. They're running out of time. We're on fumes.
整个第三幕是在明迪、BJ、吉恩和李的一个临时编剧小组中，在大约12小时内写出来的。哇。整个第三幕。我记得布伦特和我们分享过，艾丽西亚也证实了这一点，整个剧本是在最后关头才完成的。就像，这是季终集。他们积压了很多工作。时间快用完了。我们已经精疲力竭了。
We are. Randy noted that this whole episode takes place just at Dunder Mifflare. Flynn and that the production had requested that because they were getting ready for our big 100th episode season finale company picnic. They were prepping. And he said, we just couldn't afford to be going on location. We needed an episode that happened right on our set. So maybe that contributed, too, to some of these rewrites at the end.
我们是。兰迪指出，这一整集都发生在邓德·米夫林。弗林和制作组要求这样做，因为他们正准备拍摄我们第100集季终集的公司野餐。他们当时正在筹备。他说，我们实在负担不起外景拍摄。我们需要一集直接在摄影棚内完成的剧集。所以也许这也促成了最后的一些重写。
I also want to give a shout out to, you know, our unsung hero a little bit, Phil Shea, who every week had to do so much. If you go to deleted scenes, there's a scene where Jim is welcoming Pam to the Despot of Jim and Dwight and Pam now. And he gives her this little island. And on the island, it's Jim and Pam and Dwight. Okay. Okay. It's like a little figurine. Why do I not have this item? You should own this item. In the script, it was supposed to be Jim, Pam, and Dwight. And deleted scenes, It's sort of like a makeshift of that. But I guess Phil Shea spent tons of time getting this thing made. Of course.
我还想特别感谢一下我们幕后的无名英雄菲尔·谢伊，他每周都要做很多工作。如果你去看删减片段，有一个场景是吉姆欢迎帕姆加入吉姆、德怀特和帕姆的“专制统治”。他给了她这个小岛。岛上有吉姆、帕姆和德怀特。好吧。好吧。就像一个小雕像。为什么我没有这个东西？你应该拥有这个东西。在剧本里，原本应该是吉姆、帕姆和德怀特。在删减片段里，它看起来像是临时拼凑的。但我猜菲尔·谢伊花了很多时间制作这个东西。当然。
And it didn't even make it in. Yeah. Well, now we're coming up to a scene that is very famous as well. Perhaps as famous as our chilly cold open. For sure. I mean, I've seen people do this scene as a Halloween costume. So many people. It's the scene where Toby has to confront Meredith about her casual outfit, saying that it's a bit
而且它甚至没能出现在正片里。是的。好吧，现在我们要讲到一个也非常著名的场景。也许和我们著名的辣椒开场一样出名。肯定的。我是说，我见过很多人把这个场景当作万圣节装扮。太多人了。就是托比不得不找梅雷迪斯谈论她休闲装扮的场景，说那有点
revealing. So when she tugs on her skirt, it flashes her top, when she pulls it back up, then it flashes the bottom. It's a lot. It has two standout famous lines that are quoted quite a bit to Kate Flannery. Meredith, your boob is out. And damn it, Meredith, where are your panties? Well, when we talked to Brent Forrester about this episode, he told us this. He said, when he joined the writing staff of the office in season three, he noticed that the writers were sometimes having a hard time writing for the character of Meredith, who he personally loved. And he said everyone knew Kate Flannery was really funny, but they just hadn't cracked the code of this character. Brent shared that one day he was at lunch and he happened to be sitting next to
暴露。所以当她拉裙子时，会露出上身，当她把它拉回去时，又会露出下身。这太过了。它有两句非常著名的台词，经常被引用给凯特·弗兰纳里。梅雷迪斯，你的胸部露出来了。还有，该死，梅雷迪斯，你的内裤呢？好吧，当我们和布伦特·福雷斯特谈论这一集时，他告诉我们这个。他说，当他在第三季加入《办公室》编剧组时，他注意到编剧们有时很难为梅雷迪斯这个角色写剧本，而他个人很喜欢这个角色。他说大家都知道凯特·弗兰纳里很有趣，但他们就是没能破解这个角色的密码。布伦特分享说，有一天他在吃午饭，碰巧坐在
Kate, and so he just asked her, Kate, what makes you funny? And apparently Kate said something to the effect of, Brent, I'm the daughter of an old Irish bar owner. My comfort zone is loud and filthy. So he went back to the writers and he told them this and he said it revolutionized the writing for Meredith. He got credited with cracking the code. And he was like, all I did was just ask the actress. He said it was actually a good lesson. Like, go ask the actress. Like, what are you really good at? What do you like to do? What's your thing? And then the writer's room can lean into that. And you mentioned this to Kate, right? I did.
凯特旁边，所以他就问她，凯特，是什么让你变得有趣？显然凯特说了类似这样的话，布伦特，我是个老爱尔兰酒吧老板的女儿。我的舒适区就是吵闹和粗俗。所以他回到编剧室告诉了他们，他说这彻底改变了梅雷迪斯的剧本创作。他被认为是破解了密码的人。他说，我所做的只是问了演员。他说这实际上是一个很好的教训。就像，去问演员。就像，你真正擅长什么？你喜欢做什么？你的特色是什么？然后编剧室就可以顺势而为。你跟凯特提过这件事，对吧？我提过。
I was talking to Kate on the phone this week. And I said, Kate, we are coming up on casual Friday. Also, you guys, when we're recording this, Halloween has just happened. Kate is constantly tagged in photos of people dressed as Meredith in this purple dress. Yes. With sort of a pixelated boob. Yes. You know?
这周我正在和凯特通电话。我说，凯特，我们快要讲到“休闲星期五”那一集了。还有，伙计们，当我们录制这个的时候，万圣节刚刚过去。凯特经常被标记在人们打扮成穿着这件紫色裙子的梅雷迪斯的照片里。是的。带着某种像素化的胸部。是的。你知道吗？
I've seen them. Yeah. So I asked Kate about this scene. And here's what she had to share. Hey, Office Lady podcast fans, I have to tell you, when we did the table read, I knew exactly how well this was going to pull. It was so well written, the scene where Toby tells Meredith to pull up her dress. It was just, just brilliantly written and kind of like jumping out of an airplane whenever I'm topless or more. yeah because you just got to do it you can't even judge it you just got to go um and luckily paul is a great uh he's a great partner in a scene because he plays it very small and real so it reminds me to
我见过。是的。所以我问了凯特关于这个场景的事。这是她要分享的内容。嘿，《办公室女士》播客的粉丝们，我必须告诉你们，当我们进行剧本围读时，我就知道这个场景会产生多大的反响。它写得太好了，托比告诉梅雷迪斯拉起裙子的那个场景。它只是，写得太精彩了，就像从飞机上跳下来一样，每当我上身赤裸或者更多的时候。是的，因为你必须去做，你甚至不能去评判它，你只能去做。嗯，幸运的是，保罗是一个很棒的搭档，因为他演得很内敛且真实，所以这提醒我
keep it small and real and uh not always easy for me um but yeah uh it's so much fun and um there was talk of a merkin at one point a murkin is a wig for down there yeah uh luckily the pixelation at NBC. And also credit must be given to Alicia for creating this amazing dress that was so easy to hike up or hike down and have a problem. So yeah, great wardrobe malfunction dress from a great wardrobe designer, Alicia. So thank you for that. And it's one of the few things I wish I'd kept and I did not. I do have a longer version. Someday I'll wear it in public. Yeah, But, well, I'll, to save the date, you guys, hold your breath. Okay, here we go.
保持内敛和真实，嗯，对我来说并不总是那么容易，但是的，这太有趣了。而且当时有人提到过阴毛假发。阴毛假发是下面用的假发。是的，幸运的是NBC有像素化处理。而且必须归功于艾丽西亚创造了这件神奇的裙子，它非常容易拉上去或拉下来，不会有问题。所以是的，这是一件来自伟大的服装设计师艾丽西亚的伟大的服装故障裙。所以谢谢你。这是我希望保留的少数几件东西之一，但我没有。我确实有一个更长的版本。总有一天我会公开穿它。是的，但是，好吧，我会，为了留个纪念，你们，屏住呼吸。好吧，我们开始吧。
Thank you. Have a great day. And I hope it's casual day. Okay. Did you notice that her dress was also purple? I did notice that. I talked to Alicia about this dress. It was actually a bubble skirt.
谢谢。祝你有美好的一天。我希望今天是休闲日。好吧。你注意到她的裙子也是紫色的吗？我注意到了。我和艾丽西亚谈过这件裙子。它实际上是一条泡泡裙。
Yeah. It was not actually meant to be a dress. It's meant to be worn at the waist. Yeah. I love that Kate brought up the Merkin. That is like a word I forgot I even knew. Same. Oh my gosh. A Merkin is like the fake. It's faky hair down there. Finky hair down there. Oh my gosh. You know, Kate and I went on to talk on the phone about this and she shared with me that doing these nude scenes, they were definitely not in her comfort zone, you know? Mm-hmm. And every time she did them, she had to really step out of her comfort zone.
是的。它实际上并不是作为裙子设计的。它是设计穿在腰部的。是的。我喜欢凯特提到阴毛假发。那是一个我差点忘了我甚至知道的词。我也是。天哪。阴毛假发就像是假的。下面用的假发。下面用的假发。天哪。你知道，凯特和我后来在电话里谈到了这一点，她和我分享说，拍摄这些裸露场景绝对不在她的舒适区，你知道吗？嗯。每次她拍摄这些场景时，她都必须真正走出她的舒适区。
But she would just go for it. She told me she was like, Angie, I never really got used to doing these. You know, I've had to do scenes in movies where I'm wearing very little or a love scene or whatever. And it always feels awkward to me too. Yeah. Well, I also ask Kate, what was she wearing underneath this purple dress? Oh, we got a lot of fan questions about that. What was it?
但她总是会全力以赴。她告诉我，她说，安吉，我从来没有真正习惯拍摄这些。你知道，我不得不在电影里拍摄我穿得很少的场景，或者爱情戏什么的。这对我来说总是感觉很尴尬。是的。好吧，我也问了凯特，她在紫色裙子下面穿了什么？哦，我们收到了很多粉丝关于这个的问题。是什么？
She said she was wearing a flesh-toned mole skin. Yeah, you know, I used to use that when I did. ballet to wrap my toes. Yeah. You know, guys, it's like that sort of... It's like a fuzzy felt thing that sticks to your skin. Exactly. In fact, they've made it for blisters, but they use it to cover your boob area. And then the other thing she was wearing was a thong. Well, we spoke to Randy Cordray about this a little bit, and he said that he did insist on a closed set. And what that means is that normally when you're doing scenes, those scenes are broadcast backstage for the hair and makeup people to observe, to make sure everything's okay, different crew members. Anyone backstage can sort of see on a live feed what is happening on the set.
她说她穿的是肤色的鼹鼠皮贴。是的，你知道，我以前跳芭蕾舞时用它来包裹脚趾。是的。你知道吗，伙计们，它就像那种……它就像一种粘在皮肤上的毛茸茸的毡状物。没错。事实上，它们是为水泡制作的，但他们用它来覆盖你的胸部区域。然后她穿的另一件东西是丁字裤。好吧，我们和兰迪·科德雷谈过这件事，他说他确实坚持要封闭拍摄。这意味着通常当你拍摄场景时，这些场景会在后台播放，供发型和化妆人员观察，以确保一切正常，还有不同的工作人员。后台的任何人都可以通过直播看到片场正在发生的事情。
Those get shut off when you ever have a scene like this. No monitors backstage. And then similarly, no guests are allowed on those days and no photography, of course, and only. the people who need to be in the scene or on the set are allowed on the set. That's right. If you're not part of the scene, you're not there. Exactly. The next scene made me laugh because Ryan is fielding a complaint, but it's Dwight's former client. Dwight has had this client for 10 years who's never had a complaint, and now this client wants to leave. Did you catch the client's name? No. They say it over and over. I don't know why it just tickled me because I never noticed it
当你拍摄这样的场景时，那些会被关闭。后台没有监视器。同样，那些日子不允许有访客，当然也不允许拍照，只有需要出现在场景中或片场的人才被允许进入片场。没错。如果你不是场景的一部分，你就不能在那里。没错。下一个场景让我笑了，因为瑞安正在处理投诉，但那是德怀特的客户。德怀特有这个客户10年了，从来没有投诉过，现在这个客户想离开。你听到客户的名字了吗？没有。他们一遍又一遍地说。我不知道为什么它让我觉得好笑，因为我从来没注意到
before. Because you and I are truly re-watching this. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Mr. Bart. Mr. Bart. Mr. Bart. They're very sad about losing Mr. Bart, but it builds to this crescendo where Phyllis ends up tearfully saying to Michael, you know, Michael, you thought you were attacking corporate, but we were the ones who got hurt. You should be apologizing to us. And she says, Michael, you always said we were a family and then you went after us. Well, they talked in the DVD commentary about this moment that it was a very pivotal story moment because it had to flip Michael. Yes.
过。因为你和我真的是在重温这部剧。哦，是的。是的。巴特先生。巴特先生。巴特先生。他们对失去巴特先生感到非常难过，但这导致了一个高潮，菲利斯最终含泪对迈克尔说，你知道，迈克尔，你以为你在攻击公司，但受伤的是我们。你应该向我们道歉。她说，迈克尔，你总是说我们是一家人，然后你却针对我们。好吧，他们在DVD评论中谈到了这一刻，这是一个非常关键的剧情时刻，因为它必须改变迈克尔。
So they needed Phyllis to really perform in this moment. It all came down to her. And on the commentary, there was a little bit of a debate between Brent and Mindy. Mindy was like, was Phyllis being calculating? Right. Was she manipulating Michael? Right. And then Claire, Scanlon, who was also on the DVD commentary, was like, no, I think she was being sincere.
所以他们需要菲利斯在这一刻真正表现出来。一切都取决于她。在评论中，布伦特和敏迪之间有一点争论。敏迪说，菲利斯是在算计吗？对。她在操纵迈克尔吗？对。然后克莱尔·斯坎伦，她也在DVD评论中，说，不，我认为她是真诚的。
I read it as sincere. I think she played it sincere. I thought Phyllis performed it as sincere. The thing that surprised me about this whole scene was that Ryan even had a client. I know. That's so true. I don't know. I guess I thought maybe.
我读出来的是真诚的。我认为她演得很真诚。我以为菲利斯演得很真诚。关于整个场景让我惊讶的是，瑞安竟然有一个客户。我知道。那太真实了。我不知道。我猜我以为也许。
Maybe he has one. He has one. But that one's leaving. But I think big props to Phyllis because I think she. really delivered in that moment, and you see how Michael re-evaluates everything. Because he does see this office as his family. Dwight's going to write another letter in Invisible Inc. And fan catch from Carla J. who says, oh my gosh, can we please talk about how Dwight is using Ryan's Cup from Kelly's America's Got Talent Party to paint the secret urine messages onto the memos. I noticed that as well.
也许他有一个。他有一个。但那个要走了。但我认为菲利斯表现得很好，因为我认为她在那一刻确实表现出色，你看到了迈克尔是如何重新评估一切的。因为他确实把这个办公室看作他的家人。德怀特要用隐形墨水写另一封信。来自卡拉·J的粉丝捕捉，她说，天哪，我们能谈谈德怀特是如何使用瑞安从凯利的《美国达人》派对上拿来的杯子，把秘密尿液信息写在备忘录上的吗？我也注意到了这一点。
I thought it was very funny. Clearly, Dwight has peed in that cup. Listen, in the end, Michael is going to apologize to the sales force, and he's going to agree to give them their clients back. But this means he's going to have to fire, reassign one of his Michael Scott paper company employees. Yeah, he can only keep one of them on as a salesperson, and he's going to have to decide if it's Pam or Ryan. Jim is going to try to help Michael by telling him maybe he should make a list of pros and cons about each person. That doesn't go very far because Michael tries to get Jim to say some cons about Pam. And I guess what they settle on is that I have a shrill voice. Sometimes when those moments wind up in a script, I'm like, hmm, does someone in the writer's room find my voice awful?
我觉得这非常有趣。显然，德怀特在那个杯子里撒尿了。听着，最后，迈克尔要向销售团队道歉，他要同意把客户还给他们。但这意味着他将不得不解雇、重新分配他的一名迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的员工。是的，他只能留下一名销售人员，他必须决定是帕姆还是瑞安。吉姆试图通过告诉迈克尔也许他应该列出每个人的优缺点来帮助他。这没起多大作用，因为迈克尔试图让吉姆说出一些关于帕姆的缺点。我想他们达成一致的是，我的声音很刺耳。有时当这些时刻出现在剧本中时，我会想，嗯，编剧室里有人觉得我的声音很糟糕吗？
Oh, 100%. Only sometimes, they said. Only sometimes her voice is shrill. I guarantee you someone was like, well, what could we say? I don't know. Maybe her voice gets grading. Right? Yeah.
哦，百分之百。他们说，只有有时。只有有时她的声音很刺耳。我保证有人会说，好吧，我们能说什么？我不知道。也许她的声音变得刺耳了。对吧？是的。
For sure. Sorry, all you podcast listeners. I had an audition one time for a national campaign for bananas. Go on. Yeah. You had to eat a banana in the audition. And I didn't get the part. The casting director, as I was delivering my lines, she said, I'm sorry.
肯定的。抱歉，所有的播客听众。我曾经为香蕉的全国性广告试镜过。继续。是的。你必须在试镜中吃一根香蕉。我没得到那个角色。选角导演在我念台词时说，抱歉。
I'm going to stop you. Can you lower your register? And I said, oh, okay. So I have to take a bite of the banana and then say the line. Whatever the line is, these bananas are great. Whatever it was, I can't remember. But so I went, I guess I was going like, these bananas are great or something. And so then I took a bite of the banana.
我要打断你。你能降低你的音调吗？我说，哦，好吧。所以我必须咬一口香蕉，然后念台词。不管台词是什么，这些香蕉很棒。不管是什么，我不记得了。但所以我去了，我想我当时是说，这些香蕉很棒或者类似的话。所以我就咬了一口香蕉。
And you guys take a bite of banana and then try to say a line. then I'm like, these bananas are great. I didn't get it. But for the rest of my career, I thought, oh, my gosh, is my, like, is my voice shrill in grading? And I asked my agent when I didn't get it, I was like, was it because she wanted me to lower my register? Did she say something about my register? And my agent said, no. She actually said, they thought the way you ate the banana was awkward.
你们咬一口香蕉，然后试着念台词。然后我就说，这些香蕉很棒。我没得到它。但在我职业生涯的其余时间里，我想，哦，天哪，我的声音是不是很刺耳？当我没得到它时，我问我的经纪人，我说，是因为她想让我降低音调吗？她说了关于我音调的事吗？我的经纪人说，没有。她实际上说，他们认为你吃香蕉的方式很尴尬。
Oh, my gosh. How actors make it? How do you come back from that? I don't know. How does that not give you a complex? I don't know. In two areas, your voice and your banana eating. I know.
哦，天哪。演员们是怎么熬过来的？你怎么从那件事中恢复过来？我不知道。那怎么没让你产生情结？我不知道。在两个领域，你的声音和你吃香蕉的方式。我知道。
That was always such a tricky thing. You'd go to an audition and then you wouldn't get it and you would just want to know anything. You would say, was there any feedback? Any feedback. Desperate for feedback. Oh, my gosh. So you could do it better next time. So you could learn.
那总是一件棘手的事情。你去试镜，然后没得到它，你只想知道任何反馈。你会说，有什么反馈吗？任何反馈。渴望反馈。哦，天哪。这样你下次就能做得更好。这样你就能学习。
And then you find out you sound like a banshee and you eat a banana like a f*** idiot. Exactly. And then when are you going to use that information? What's your next banana eating role that you can apply that to? I will never eat a banana on camera. Let me tell you. All right. Can we talk about this scene where everyone is ganging up on Toby about casual Friday because it's delightful?
然后你发现你听起来像个女妖，吃香蕉像个该死的白痴。没错。然后你什么时候会用到这些信息？你的下一个吃香蕉的角色是什么，你可以应用到那个角色上？我再也不会在镜头前吃香蕉了。让我告诉你。好吧。我们能谈谈这个每个人都在“休闲星期五”上针对托比的场景吗，因为它太有趣了？
All right. When you guys watch it, when Toby says it's canceled, everyone is like, boo. And Angela, full smile jumping up and down. Yay. Yay. But Dwight starts to take over this meeting, and he says that you could still have casual Friday, but he's going to give a few rules, like earth tones only. And did you hear this one at 18 minutes, 13 seconds? Women are forbidden to wear pants. Huh. Who has Dwight been talking to? An executive at NBC, perhaps? I wonder where that one came from. I'll tell you what's going to happen, boys. Once they start wearing pants, they're going to want things. Like, you know, equal rights. I don't know. Which, by the way, I'm sorry. Soapbox moment. Can you believe that there is still not a ratified equal rights amendment? That in our Constitution, the fabric of our nation, women are still not seen? as equal legally? What the F is that? Now, the states have finally, there's enough that have ratified this amendment, but I guess they did it a little bit too late. They missed the deadline because it took, like, how many years? Over 20, 25 years? 30 years. So anyway, I guess they're trying to fix that loophole and say that we should ratify this amendment already. I say about time. And women can wear
好吧。当你们看的时候，当托比说它被取消时，每个人都说，嘘。安吉拉满脸笑容地跳上跳下。耶。耶。但德怀特开始接管这个会议，他说你仍然可以有休闲星期五，但他要给出一些规则，比如只能穿大地色系。你在18分13秒听到这个了吗？禁止女性穿裤子。嗯。德怀特一直在和谁说话？也许是NBC的高管？我想知道那个是从哪里来的。我告诉你们会发生什么，伙计们。一旦她们开始穿裤子，她们就会想要东西。比如，你知道，平权。我不知道。顺便说一句，抱歉。演讲时刻。你能相信仍然没有批准《平权修正案》吗？在我们的宪法中，我们国家的基石，女性仍然没有被视为法律上的平等吗？那是什么鬼东西？现在，各州终于，有足够的州批准了这个修正案，但我猜他们做得有点太晚了。他们错过了截止日期，因为它花了，大概多少年？超过20、25年？30年。所以无论如何，我想他们正在试图修复那个漏洞，并说我们应该批准这个修正案了。我说时候到了。女性可以穿
whatever they want on the bottom. And we can show our panty lines and we can have pockets and we can have equal rights under the law. Thank you. Call your representatives. Ask for all of them. They'll be confused by the pockets and panty lines, but just doesn't matter. Okay. Clearly, we're going to Washington. Could you imagine me in Washington testifying before Congress? I would love to Love it. I would love it. I would want you to wear the biggest, baggiest pants. I would have pockets from my waist down to my effing ankles. When one of the old men that's on Congress asked you a question, I would want you to stand up in your pants and say, one second, and you pull a full laptop out of one of your pockets. And you know, but here's the thing. In the back, they fit really tight so you can see my panty line. And it's going to be.
任何她们想穿的下装。我们可以露出内裤痕迹，我们可以有口袋，我们可以在法律下拥有平等的权利。谢谢。给你们的代表打电话。要求他们所有人。他们会被口袋和内裤痕迹搞糊涂，但这没关系。好吧。显然，我们要去华盛顿。你能想象我在华盛顿在国会前作证吗？我很乐意。喜欢它。我很乐意。我会让你穿最大、最宽松的裤子。我会从腰部到该死的脚踝都有口袋。当国会里的老头之一问你问题时，我会想让你站起来，穿着你的裤子说，等一下，然后你从你的一个口袋里掏出一台完整的笔记本电脑。你知道，但这就是重点。在后面，它们穿起来很紧，所以你可以看到我的内裤痕迹。而且它会是。
the harshest panty line you've ever seen. Your target laundry day undies. A hundred percent. And then I'm going to say, ratify that amendment already. And then when it's ratified, you're going to say, see, you gave us pants and we took over your fear about us in pants. It came true. That's right. All right. All right. Michael is going to call Pam into his office, and we are going to find out who got the sales job. Was it, Pam? Was it Ryan? Michael. He's got to prank you first. This man loves a fake fire and a fake hire.
你见过的最明显的内裤痕迹。你洗衣服那天穿的内裤。百分之百。然后我会说，批准那个修正案吧。然后当它被批准时，你会说，看，你给了我们裤子，我们接管了你对我们穿裤子的恐惧。它成真了。没错。好吧。好吧。迈克尔要叫帕姆去他的办公室，我们要找出谁得到了销售工作。是帕姆吗？是瑞安吗？迈克尔。他得先捉弄你。这个人喜欢假火灾和假招聘。
He loves it. What is that about him? He tells Pam he's really sorry, but he gave Ryan the sales job. Yeah. And Pam is disappointed. And then he starts to giggle. Yeah, he's joking. And she's like, Michael.
他喜欢它。关于他，那是什么？他告诉帕姆他很抱歉，但他把销售工作给了瑞安。是的。帕姆很失望。然后他开始咯咯笑。是的，他在开玩笑。她说，迈克尔。
Yeah. He offered Ryan his temp job back, and Pam is going to get this. sales position. She's so happy about it. She is. As she's leaving the office, Michael says, send Aaron in. Oh, no. So you know he's about to do some prank on Aaron. I want you guys to know that that is where the scene ended. In the shooting draft, he says send Aaron in. There's no more dialogue. Oh, yes. Brent told us this. Brent said that this scene coming up was Ellie Kemper's first one-on-one scene with Steve Correll.
是的。他把瑞安的临时工工作还给了他，帕姆要得到这个。销售职位。她对此非常高兴。她是。当她离开办公室时，迈克尔说，让艾伦进来。哦，不。所以你知道他要对艾伦搞恶作剧了。我想让你们知道，这就是场景结束的地方。在拍摄草稿中，他说让艾伦进来。没有更多的对话了。哦，是的。布伦特告诉我们这个。布伦特说，即将到来的这个场景是艾莉·坎伯与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的第一个一对一场景。
But it wasn't even supposed to happen. It was all improv. That is amazing. So basically they just let the cameras keep rolling. He says send Aaron in. Aaron walks in. And then Steve and Aaron do this little improvised scene. And they loved it.
但它甚至不应该发生。这全是即兴表演。这太神奇了。所以基本上他们只是让摄像机继续转动。他说让艾伦进来。艾伦走进来。然后史蒂夫和艾伦做了这个即兴的小场景。他们很喜欢它。
And it made it into the episode. That is amazing. That closes out casual Friday. I loved this episode. I loved this podcast. I loved, loved this episode so much, too. And we have some shoutouts and some thank yous. We really do.
它被放进了这一集。这太神奇了。这结束了“休闲星期五”。我喜欢这一集。我喜欢这个播客。我也非常非常喜欢这一集。我们有一些特别感谢和一些致谢。我们确实有。
Thank you, Brian Baumgartner, for being our guest. Everyone, remember to check out his book. Welcome to Dunder Mifflin. And his new podcast coming out next year. Off the beat. We need to thank Randy Cordray, Alicia Raycraft, Kate Flannery, Creed Bratt, and John Krasinski. Thank you for letting us hit you up all the time for your scoop on these episodes. Seriously, God bless you guys, because as we share a lot with you all,
谢谢布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳成为我们的嘉宾。大家，记得去看看他的书。《欢迎来到邓德·米夫林》。还有他明年出的新播客。《Off the Beat》。我们需要感谢兰迪·科德雷、艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特、凯特·弗兰纳里、克里德·布拉顿和约翰·卡拉辛斯基。谢谢你们让我们一直打扰你们，获取这些剧集的内幕。说真的，上帝保佑你们，因为正如我们与你们所有人分享的那样，
listening. We text these guys and call them all the time. I know. I'm like, hey, John, how's it going? Weird question. Are you a good chess player? Yeah. Hey, Credo, how's it going? Listen, I left some limes on your porch. Also, can you play chess? I know, Pete, there must be like, what is happening? And finally, thank you to Brent Forrester, our longtime writer on the office, who also directed this episode. Guys, you know, Brent teaches comedy writing classes that anyone can take, and you can find him and those classes over at Brentforester.com, we highly recommend. If you have a creative idea that you want to turn into a comedy show, this is a good place to start. Yes, and check out Kate and Creed. You guys, they both have some wonderful shows coming up. You can find them on Instagram at the
听众们。我们一直给这些人发短信和打电话。我知道。我就像，嘿，约翰，怎么样？奇怪的问题。你是国际象棋高手吗？是的。嘿，克里德，怎么样？听着，我在你的门廊上留了一些青柠。还有，你会下国际象棋吗？我知道，皮特，他们一定在想，发生了什么事？最后，感谢布伦特·福雷斯特，我们《办公室》的长期编剧，他也执导了这一集。伙计们，你们知道，布伦特教任何人都可以参加的喜剧写作课程，你们可以在Brentforester.com找到他和那些课程，我们强烈推荐。如果你有一个想要变成喜剧节目的创意，这是一个很好的起点。是的，去看看凯特和克里德。伙计们，他们都有一些精彩的节目要播出。你们可以在Instagram上找到他们，账号是
Real Kate Plenary and at Creed Bratton. And we will see you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Real Kate Plenary和Creed Bratton。我们下周见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。